STARTED- LOOKING TOWARD JOINT
HEARING ON CANNABIS I AM
EXTREMELY HAPPY THAT CULTURE
THIS HEARING WITH- MY COLLEAGUE
MISTER LOCAL. WE'RE HOLDING HIS
HEARING IN ANTICIPATION OF THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL ON
CONSULTING THE EXISTING
LICENSING RESPONSIBILITIES
ADMINISTERED BY THE BUREAU OF
CANNABIS CONTROL. THE
DEPARTMENT OF FOOD AGRICULTURE.
DEPARTMENT PUBLIC HEALTH IN
THEIR DEPARTMENT CANNABIS
CONTROL BY JULY OF TWENTY
TWENTY ONE. THE GOALS TO
IDENTIFY ANY ISSUES THAT SHOULD
BE DISCUSSED WITH CONSIDERING
CONSOLIDATION INCLUDING
EFFICIENCIES STREAMLINING OF
RESOURCES AND ENFORCEMENT. MR
LOW. THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK
YOU VERY MUCH MISTER CHAIRMAN-
SIMILARLY- THE GOVERNOR
ANNOUNCED THAT THERE WOULD BE
MAJOR REORGANIZATION PLANS TO
HAVE THE STATE CURRENTLY
REGULATES CANNABIS AND AS WE
ALL KNOW THE IMPERATIVE NATURE
TO WHICH WE ENGAGE IN PRAGUE
STAKEHOLDER INPUT WHICH- THIS
IS PART OF THAT. CONVERSATION
THAT'S WHY IT'S IMPORTANT FOR
THE MINISTRATION TO REGULARLY
CONSULT WITH THE LEGISLATURE AS
IT DEVELOPS THE DETAILS FOR
THESE PROPOSALS AND SIMILARLY
ANY REORGANIZATION TO BE CHIEF
THROUGH STRONG PARTNERSHIP WITH
THIS LEGISLATURE AND THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE- SO I THINK-
OTHER EXPECTED MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE AND LOOK FOR TO THE-
ADDITIONAL CONVERSATION. MISS
LACKEY. I DON'T KNOW IF YOU
REALLY WANT ME TO TALK. BECAUSE
I'LL BE HONEST WITH YOU. THE
APATHY THAT WE HAVE UP HERE. AS
PART OF THE PROBLEM. PART OF
THE PROBLEM IS. THE ILLICIT
MARKET IS ABSOLUTELY.
DOMINATING IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA NO ONE SEEMS TO CARE.
AND I THINK THAT- THIS IS A
GREAT STEP. MAKES SENSE AND
HOPEFULLY BY DOING THIS WE CAN
ADDRESS THE ENFORCEMENT ASPECT
OF THE ILLICIT MARKET. SO I'M
ALL YOURS. THANK YOU. WE'LL
START WITH OUR OVERVIEW THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL REALLY TO
CANNABIS REGULATION AN ANALYSIS
OF ILLICIT MARKET AND FORSMAN
EFFORTS. HELLO KIRSTEIN. GOOD
AFTERNOON HEARING MEMBERS HOW
INCREASING WITH THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE AS THE SURGEON
SHOULD HAVE PASSED OUT- THREE
DIFFERENT DOCUMENTS FOR YOU
FIRST THERE'S A HEARING HAND
OUT NOT BE I'M SPEAKING FROM A
HANDOUT TODAY AND THERE ARE TWO
OTHER REPORTS THAT- HOPEFULLY
YOU HAVE WITH A PASSED OUT TO
YOU AS WELL ONE IS A REPORT
THAT WE DID BACK IN DECEMBER OF
TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN. IT TALKS
ABOUT- CANNABIS TAXES AND ALL
REFERENCE THAT BRIEFLY AND THEN
THERE'S ANOTHER REPORT THAT WE
RELEASED EARLIER THIS YEAR-
THAT SHOULD ALSO BE PROVIDED TO
YOU AND THAT REPORT IS- I'VE
REPORT WE DID ON THAT BUDGET.
PROPOSALS SO I'M GONNA STAT MY
REMARKS- WITH SOME QUICK
BACKGROUND ON CANNABIS AND PROP
SIXTY FOUR THEN I'LL BRIEFLY
SUMMARIZE THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSALS. AND IDENTIFY SOME
ISSUES FOR LEGISLATIVE
CONSIDERATION. SO IF YOU TURN
TO PAGE ONE OF THE HAND OUT. ON
THEIR SOME BRIEF BACKGROUND AS-
I'M SURE ALL OF YOU KNOW PROP
SIXTY FOUR. SIXTY FOUR ADULTS
TWENTY ONE OR OLDER CAN LEGALLY
GROW POSSESS AND USE CANNABIS
FOR NONMEDICAL PURPOSES- THE
MEASURE ALSO CREATED A
REGULATORY STRUCTURE FOR
CANNABIS- AND AS PART OF THAT
IT DELEGATED RESPONSIBILITIES
TO VARIOUS STATE DEPARTMENTS-
ONE OF THE KEY RESPONSIBILITY.
IS LICENSING OR THREE SEPARATE
DEPARTMENTS THAT HAVE ROLES
CURRENTLY FOR LICENSING
CANNABIS BUSINESSES- YOU'LL
HEAR FROM THOSE DEPARTMENT
SHORTLY. ONE OF THEM IS THE
PURE OF CANNABIS CONTROL WITHIN
THE DEPARTMENT OF CONSUMER
AFFAIRS THERE'S ALSO THIS WHEN
THE DEPARTMENT OF FOOD AND
AGRICULTURE AND THE DEPARTMENT
OF PUBLIC HEALTH. SO THEY
REGULATE RETAILERS DISTRIBUTORS
CULTIVATORS AND MANUFACTURERS.
SO PROPERTY FOR ALSO
ESTABLISHED A SYSTEM OF TAXING.
TYPICALLY TO STATE EXCISE
TAXES. I THOSE ARE ADMINISTERED
BY THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
TAX AND FEE ADMINISTRATION SO
THE FIRST TAXES A 15% TAX. ON
RETAIL GROSS RECEIPTS WE I
REFER TO THAT OFTEN AS THE
RETAIL EXCISE TAX. AND THE
SECOND IS A WEIGHT BASED TAX-
WHICH IS ALSO REFERRED TO AS
THE CULTIVATION TAX. IF YOU
TURN THE PAGE TWO OF A HAND
OUT- WE KNOW THE CULTIVATORS
AND RETAILERS BET BEAR THE
LEGAL RESPONSIBILITY FOR
ADMITTING THE TO TAXES I
MENTIONED THAT CULTIVATION IN
RETAIL EXCISE TAXES. HOWEVER
PURSUANT TO SOME TRAILER BILL
THAT WAS PASSED IN TWO THOUSAND
SEVENTEEN IT'S ACTUALLY FINAL
DISTRIBUTORS TO REMIT THE TAXES
TO SEE TFA. SO THIS RESULTS IN
KIND OF A MULTI STEP PROCESS
FOR HAVING THE TAXES- FLOW
THROUGH TO CD TFA. SO IF YOU
LOOK AT THE FIGURE ON THAT
PAGE- IT'S HER HIGHLIGHTS THAT
PROCESS THIS IS THE EXAM SIMPLE
MANUFACTURED PRODUCTS. IN SOME
CASES IF IT'S A VERY IF IT'S
COMPLEX MANUFACTURED PRODUCTS
IT ACTUALLY MIGHT HAVE MORE
STEPS BECAUSE IT MIGHT GO
THROUGH MORE MANUFACTURERS. BUT
IN THIS CASE THE CULTIVATE
WOULD REMAIN THE TAXES TO THE
FIRST DISTRIBUTOR. THEN TO A
MANUFACTURER FOR MANUFACTURING
THEN TO THE LAST DISTRIBUTOR
AND THEN PRIOR TO GOING TO THE
RETAILER- THE PRICE GOING THE
RETAILER TAX WOULD BE PERMITTED
TO SEE THE TFA. I ALSO JUST
WANT TO KNOW IT'S ACTUALLY
LITTLE BIT MORE. EVEN ON THE
RETAIL SIDE AND THE REASON FOR
THAT IS THAT. RETAILERS
GENERALLY HAVE TO MAKE PAYMENTS
THEIR TAX PAYMENTS I BEFORE
THEY MAKE A RETAIL SALE THEY
ACTUALLY TO MAKE IT WHEN THEY
PURCHASE THE PRODUCT. FROM THE
WHOLESALER. SO BECAUSE OF THAT
THE PRODUCT THAT TAX ACTUALLY
HAS TO BE BASICALLY WHOLESALE
TAX. EVEN THOUGH SERVE IN
STATUTES RETAIL TAX SO
ESSENTIALLY CITY TFA IS CHARGED
WITH COMING UP WITH THE HOLES
OF TAX EQUIVALENT. TO THAT
RETAIL PRICE TAX AND THAT'S
CALLED THE MARK UP. SO THAT'S
KIND OF ANY OTHER MINISTRY TO
STOP THAT THE TFA. MUST PERFORM.
SO IF YOU TURN TO PAGE THREE.
WE SUMMARIZE THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSALS THEIR TWO MAIN PIECES
AS AS WAS DISCUSSED EARLIER THE
FIRST IS CHANGING THE POINT OF
COLLECTION FOR CAP THE CANNABIS
TAXES SO THAT BUDGET TRAILER
LEGISLATION PROPOSES TO SHIFT
THE RESPONSIBILITY FOR OMITTING
THE CULTIVATION TAX. FROM SORRY
TO THE FROM THE FINAL
DISTRIBUTOR TO THE FIRST
DISTRIBUTOR. AND RESPONSIBILITY
FOR REMITTING THE RETAIL EXCISE
TAX FROM THE FINAL DISTRIBUTOR
TO THE RETAIL TO THE RETAILER.
THE GOVERNOR INDICATES ALSO
THAT HE'S CONSIDERING SOME
OTHER TAX CHANGES TO
POTENTIALLY TO THE TAX SYSTEM
IN TAX RATES BUT WE HAVE IT-
HEARD ANY DETAILS ON WHAT THAT
MIGHT BE. SO SECOND THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSING TO
CONSOLIDATE LICENSING FUNCTIONS
AS WE HEARD WITHIN A NEW
DEPARTMENT. SO AS I MENTIONED
BEFORE CURRENTLY THERE ARE
THREE LICENSING DEPARTMENTS AND
THOSE FUNCTIONS WOULD BE
CONSOLIDATED INTO A NEW ENTITY
KNOWN AS- THE DEPARTMENT CAMPUS
CONTROL. THE ADMINISTRATION
HASN'T PROVIDED ANY DETAILS YET
ON THIS PROPOSAL AND
ANTICIPATES PROVIDING THAT
SOMETIME IN THE SPRING. SO IF
YOU TURN TO PAGE FOUR WE
HIGHLIGHT A COUPLE OF ISSUES
FOR LEGISLATIVE CONSIDERATION
FIRST WITH REGARD TO THE POINT
OF COLLECTION WE FIND THAT AT.
THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL SHOULD
IMPROVE TAX ADMINISTRATION
COMPLIANCE THE MAIN REASON FOR
THAT IS THAT THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL WOULD. BASICALLY
IMPROVE THE NEXUS BETWEEN- THE
TAX ACTIVITY AND RESPONSIBILITY
FOR OMITTING TAXES IT WOULD
REDUCE THAT FOR OF HANDS
BASICALLY THAT THOSE TAXES HAVE
TO GO THROUGH. IT ALSO WOULD
ELIMINATE THE NEED FOR THAT
MARKET CALCULATION THAT I
MENTIONED PREVIOUSLY. SO I
STATURE THE LEGISLATURE RETAINS
THE RETAIL EXCISING CULTIVATION
TAX WE RECOMMEND THAT THE
LEGISLATURE APPROVED THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL IN THAT
AREA. HOWEVER AS WE MENTIONED
IN OUR DECEMBER REPORT WHICH
HOPEFULLY YOU HAVE A WE
ACTUALLY ALSO RECOMMEND SOME
ADDITIONAL CHANGES. TO THE
CALIFORNIA- TO CANNABIS TAXES
AS WELL AS THEIR RATES. SO
SECONDLY ON THE ISSUE OF
CONSOLIDATING LICENSING
FUNCTIONS WE THINK THE GENERAL
CONCEPT MAKES A LOT OF SENSE WE
THINK IT HAS THE POTENTIAL. TO
IMPROVE THE EFFECTIVENESS OF
CANNABIS LICENSING ENFORCEMENT
ACTIVITIES. FOR EXAMPLE WE
THINK IT COULD IMPROVE THE
ACCOUNTABILITY THE SYSTEM FOLKS
WILL KNOW THERE'S ONE ENTITY TO
GO GO TO FOR ALL THESE THESE
THESE ISSUES CURRENTLY WITH
THREE DIFFERENT APARTMENT. A
TRICKY FOR FOLKS TO KNOW KIND
OF. YOU TO GET THE ANSWERS
FROM. AND SOMETIMES THEY MIGHT
GET. ANSWERS THAT AREN'T
ENTIRELY CONSISTENT SO WE THINK
THERE'S A LOT OF POTENTIAL
ADVANTAGE TO HAVING ONE ENTITY-
HOWEVER WE NOTE THAT. A LOT OF
THEIR- DETAILS ARE GONNA BE
VERY IMPORTANT AND SO THE
LEGISLATURE'S REALLY GOING TO
WANT TO DRILL DOWN. AND MAKE
SURE THAT THE WAY IT'S
SPECIFICALLY GOING TO BE
IMPLEMENTED CONSISTENT WITH ITS
PRIORITIES. SO ACCORDINGLY
WOULD YOU RECOMMEND THAT THE
LEGISLATURE REQUESTS THE
ADMINISTRATION PROVIDE. I THESE
DETAILS AS SOON AS THEY CAN ON
HIM HOPEFULLY SOONER IN THE
SPRING RATHER THAN LATER FOR
EXAMPLE- BECAUSE IT. CAN BE
VERY DIFFICULT FOR THE
LEGISLATURE TO EVALUATE THIS OF
COMPLEX PUT. IT'S PER. PROCESS
SO HAPPY TO TAKE ANY QUESTIONS
YOU. THANK YOU TO SEE TFA IN IT
MISTER SO MORE LIKE FOR
CANDIDACY FOR ALCOHOL OR
TOBACCO. SO I'M I'M A BRING MY
COLLEAGUES- STAFF CHRISSY UP
HERE AS WELL. SEC CHRISTINE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE
SO- AT CD TFA- ADMINISTERS A-
WIDE VARIETY OF TAX AND FEE
PROGRAM CERTAINLY- ALCOHOL AND
TOBACCO TAXES- ARE AMONG THEM
AND PROVIDE SOME INSTRUCTIVE
SORTS POINTS OF. COMPARISON FOR
CANNABIS TAXES AND SO THERE ARE
SOME SURFACE SIMILARITIES AND
DIFFERENCES BETWEEN THOSE I'M
HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY FURTHER
SPECIFIC QUESTIONS YOU MAY HAVE.
LOOK YET THANK YOU VERY MUCH OF.
IT WAS A YOUR SUGGESTING HOW
FROM THE BEHALF OF THE LA- WITH
RESPECT TO. CODIFYING SOME OF
THE PROPOSALS ON A TAXATION ON
THE REFORMS OF THE TAXATION-
THERE ARE SOME APPROVALS ON
LOWERING EXCISING CULTIVATION
SIMILARLY AS YOU WELL KNOW THAT
IS. DISTINCT FROM THE LA OWES A
PROPOSED- CHANGES UNTIL IF YOU
IF YOU HAVE ANYTHING TO SPEAK
UP ON THAT WITH RESPECT TO- THE
REPORT THAT YOU PROVIDED. YEAH
SO IN THE RIVER WE DID IN
DECEMBER WE DID TALK ABOUT CAN
THIS TAXRATES- SO ESSENTIALLY-
WE LOOKED AT WE HAD A CHARGE
SPECIFICALLY UNDER PROP SIXTY.
PROP SIXTY FOUR AT OUR OFFICE
OKAY THE ATTACKS MAKES A
RECOMMENDATION TO ACHIEVE THREE
PER. UNDER THE LIST MARKET I
WOULD USING YOUTH USE AND
RAISING SUFFICIENT REVENUES TO
FUND THE PROGRAMS ENUMERATED IN
THE MEASURE. SO AS PART OF THAT
WORD FACE THE ANALYZED IT'S IF
HE'S BASICALLY WE ALL EYES OF
THE STRUCTURE. I'M ONE OF THE
THINGS WE DETERMINED IS. FELT
THAT THE CALL XIN TAXES A
RELATIVELY WEAK TAX IT DIDN'T
HAVE A LOT OF ADVANTAGES.
BECAUSE BASICALLY YOU KNOW THE
OTHER TAXES COULD COULD COULD
HAVE ACHIEVED FAME GOALS I'M AT
THE MINISTRY OF A MORE COMPLEX
I'M SO WE RAISED SOME CONCERNS
ABOUT THEIR RECOMMENDING IF YOU
KEEP RETAIL EFFECT ACTS GETTING
CULTIVATION TAX- WE ALSO HAVE-
POTENTIAL OPTIONS FOR HIS AS
WELL BUT WHAT WE THINK. I'M
MORE CONSIDERATE. CARE IF. YOU
THE CALL TAX TO KEEP THREE
TALKS I TAX AMERICAN. WE DO
HAVE SOME RAY THAT WE WERE. AND
BASICALLY. IN PRACTICE WOULD BE
REVENUE OR POTENTIALLY
SUBSTANTIAL TECH CUTS SO WE
THINK YOU COULD DO BASICALLY A
TAX CUT AND PROBABLY STILL
RAISE SUFFICIENT REVENUES IT
YOU HAVE TO SORT OF- STRUCTURE
THAT NET. SO THAT YOU DON'T DO
IT SO MUCH THAT YOU DON'T BUT
YOU CAN'T REVENUES.
SUBSTANTIALLY BUT- WE DO HAVE A
THINK BETWEEN FIFTEEN AND 20%
IF YOU JUST KEEP THAT RETAIL
TAX. ON IT IF YOU WERE TO
ACTUALLY GET RETAIN THAT
CULTIVATION TAX THE RICH WOULD
BE SOMEWHAT DIFFERENT. SO I
DON'T KNOW IF THAT ANSWERS YOUR
QUESTION BUT WE DID BUT THAT
THE TAX RATES AS PART OF THAT
WORK. THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND
THEN AT THE NEXT AND WITH
RESPECT TO THE CONCERN POSITION
OF LICENSING FUNCTIONS INTO A
NEW DEPARTMENT. A SIMILE AS YOU
WELL KNOW AND THE DEPARTMENT OF
CONSUMER AFFAIRS BCC AND A
NUMBER OF OTHER ENTITIES A
TYPICALLY THE LEGISLATURE WOULD
RETAIN ITS OVERSIGHT CAPACITY
ON THE SUNSET. THAT WOULD BE
REQUIRED ON A NUMBER OF
DIFFERENT ENTITIES UNDER
DEPARTMENT OF CONSUMER AFFAIRS
AND SIMILARLY THERE'S BEEN
CONVERSATIONS ABOUT THIS THE
EFFORTS. ON BCC BUT HE SAID
WHEN THERE MIGHT BE A PROPOSAL
FOR CONSOLIDATION IN THE
DEPARTMENT. WHERE MIGHT THE
LEGISLATURE AND ENSURE THE
ABILITY FOR. THE OVERSIGHT
OVERSIGHT FOR THE- BRAND IT'S-
I THE NEXT QUESTION I THAT'S
PROBABLY WHEN IT COMES. THAT'LL
WILL KEEP IN MY AS IT. IT LOOKS
AT THE- OF THE PROPOSAL I'M
POTENTIAL I MEAN I THINK THERE%
FREDDIE A POTENTIAL OPTIONS SO
IT COULD REMAIN WITHIN ON
BUSINESS AND PROFESSIONS
POTENTIALLY AND THERE COULD THE
OVERSIGHT CONTINUE THEIR IT
COULD BE WITHIN A DIFFERENT
DEPARTMENT. SORRY A DIFFERENT
COMMITTEE ON DEPENDING ON SORT
OF YOU KNOW THE CHOICES OF THE
LEGISLATURE- BUT WE DO THINK
THAT CONTINUED OVERSIGHT IN
THIS AREA IS EXTREMELY
IMPORTANT BOTH ON THE POLICY
SIDE AND OF COURSE ON THE
BACKSIDE AS WELL- IT'S- OF
COURSE AN AREA THAT HAS. NOT
ONLY WATCH LEGISLATIVE
INTERESTS BUT IT'S SUCH A NEW
AREA AND THERE'S SO MUCH GOING
ON. THAT IT'S REALLY THE KIND
OF THE KIND OF TOPIC THAT OPENS
ITSELF TO REALLY ROBUST
OVERSIGHT SO I THINK THAT'S ONE
OF THE THINGS THAT- YOU KNOW
THE DETAILS COULD YOU. COULD BE
OUT THAT PROPERTY THAT. THE
PROCESS BUT WE THINK IT'S
CERTAINLY IS A CRITICAL
FUNCTION FOR LEGISLATURE
PERFORM. WELL HOW BOUT EVEN AT
THE SIMPLISTIC NATURE TO WHICH
IS. SIMILARLY WITHIN ANY OTHER
ENTITIES ON THE DEPARTMENT OF
CONSUMER AFFAIRS HAS THE LA-
GIVEN ANYTHING TO THAT. ON I'M
I'M NOT ENTIRELY IF ON SO I'M
ANSWERING YOUR- I THINK THAT
THE SUN. OF YOUR- OF A VERY.
PROCESS FOR OVERSIGHT- AND NOT
PROCESS- I THINK. IS A VERY-
WELL ESTABLISHED AND- AND GOOD
PROCESS FOR ENSURING OVERSIGHT
SO THAT CERTAINLY COULD BE A
MODEL FOR THAT COULD BE USED
WHETHER IT'S WITHIN BUSINESS
AND PROFESSIONS ARE ANOTHER
COMMITTEE. OF COURSE THAT'S UP
TO THE LEGISLATURE BUT- BUT I
THINK THAT PROCESS THAT TYPE OF
PROCESS IS REALLY. VERY VERY
VALUABLE ONE BECAUSE THAT
SUBJECTS. THE HIGH THESE
ENTITIES TO I THINK VERY
SIGNIFICANT REVIEW AND
OVERSIGHT AND THEY KIND OF HAVE
TO PERIODICALLY COME FORWARD
AND- AND REALLY EXPLAIN WHAT
THEY'RE DOING AND MAKES AND IF
THE LEGISLATURE GREAT
OPPORTUNITY TO MAKE SURE THAT-
THAT IT STILL COMFORTABLE WITH.
THE PATH HAT THEY'RE GOING ON
SO I THINK THAT'S A GREAT MODEL
BUT OF COURSE IT COULD BE-
COULD BE SHIFTED IF THE FACT
THAT THESE ARE AS WELL. THANK
YOU AND I THINK THE IMPORTANCE
IS THAT WE WANT TO HAVE BROUGHT
STAKEHOLDER INPUT IN. AND
ACTUALLY PROVIDES THE
LEGISLATIVE PROCESS FOR PUBLIC
INPUT IN PRAGUE COLDER
ENGAGEMENT. AND FINALLY SIMILE
IS IT YOUR ASSESSMENT THAT-
WITH THE RE ORDER OF- THE
DEPARTMENT THAT LEGISLATIVE
APPROVAL WOULD BE REQUIRED FOR
THAT AS WELL. YEAH SO I THINK
UNDER THE- UNDER THAT WE
UNDERSTAND THAT THIS IS LIKELY
TO. HE PROPOSES TRAILER BILL
LEGISLATION AND OF COURSE THAT
WOULD BE HEARD. AND TO BUDGET
PROCESS AND THE BUDGET
COMMITTEE AS WELL AS A FULL
LEGISLATURE. OR OTHER PROCESS
THAT CAN BE USED AS WELL FOR
EXAMPLE SUMMARY OR IS IN THE
PAST HAVE GONE THROUGH A
GOVERNOR'S WE ARE PROCESS.
COURSE THAT WOULD ALSO GO
THROUGH THE LEGISLATURE SO THE
LEGISLATURE HAS A REALLY
IMPORTANT ROLE IN CONSIDERING
THESE PROPOSALS AND DECIDING
WHETHER THEY'RE CUT WHETHER THE
LEGISLATURE'S COMFORTABLE WITH
THE PROPOSAL OR WANT TO MAKE
CHANGES. I'M WHATEVER IT
PROCESSES USED WE THINK THAT'S
REALLY CRITICAL AND THAT'S WHY
WE RECOMMEND THAT THE THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION PROVIDE DETAILS
SOONER RATHER THAN. LATER WE
THINK THAT'LL MORE TIME. I'M IN
AN ARTS. YOU KNOW WHEN
PROPOSALS FOR COME. YOU KNOW
I'VE MAYOR OF. WHICH SOMETIMES
THEY DO. I'M A CAN IT LEAVES
VERY LITTLE TIME FOR THE
LEGISLATURE TO ASSESS THOSE
PROPOSALS- BECAUSE THERE'S JUST
ESPECIALLY WITH THAT THE
DEADLINES THAT THE
LEGISLATURE'S UNDER IT- IN
PRACTICE IT IT. DOESN'T GIVE A
LOT OF TIME FOR CONSIDERATION
SO WE THINK THAT IF THAT
PROPOSALS COULD COME IN.
EARLIER THAN NOT THAT WOULD
THAT WOULD BE BENEFICIAL TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE HAVE A ROBUST
CONVERSATION. IT'S WILL FOLLOW
UP COME HAVE YOU CONSIDERED.
LOOKING AT HE- MOVING THE
RETAIL TAX TO DISTRIBUTION
INSTEAD. APPOINT A CELLS IS
PROPOSED BY THE ADMINISTRATION.
US SO- FOR THE DECEMBER REPORT
THAT- THAT MY COLLEAGUE HAS
REFERRED TO WE EXAMINE WE
SERVE. THOUGHT ABOUT POTENTIAL
CHANGES TO- CANNABIS THE
STATE'S CAMPUS EXCISE TAXES IS
SORT OF A THREE STEP PROCESS
FIRST CHOOSING WHAT TYPE OF TAX
OR TAXES TO LET THE SECOND.
CHOOSING HOW TO COLLECT THEM IN
THIRD DETERMINING THE RATE AND
SO- WE DID CONSIDER FOR EACH
TYPE OF TAX THAT WE LOOKED AT
IN THE REPORT WE CONSIDERED-
SEVERAL DIFFERENT POSSIBLE
POINTS OF COLLECTION INCLUDING-
THE FINAL DISTRIBUTION AND AS
WELL AS AS THE RETAILER- SO
ULTIMATELY WE FOR A POTENCY
BASED TAX WE THINK THAT EITHER
THE FINAL DISTRIBUTION OR-
RETAILER COULD BE A REASONABLE
POINT OF COLLECTION BUT FOR
PRICE BASED TAXES. ALSO KNOWN
AS AT VALOREM TAXES WHETHER
THAT'S LIKE THE CURRENT RETAIL
EXCISE TAX WE HAVE OR SOME-
ALTERNATIVE THAT COULD BE AT
LAST DISTRIBUTION. IN THOSE
SCENARIOS- WE DID RECOMMEND-
COLLECTING THOSE AT THE RETAIL
LEVEL- AND THE REASON WAS SOME
OF THE REASONS FOR THAT ARE AT
TAX ADMINISTRATION FORCED AND
IT HELPFUL TO HAVE TAXPAYERS
THAT PLAY A CONSISTENT ROLE IN
APPLY CHAIN ARE READILY
IDENTIFIABLE INVISIBLE BOTH TO
TAP MINISTERS IN PUBLIC. AND
ALSO HAVE AN ESTABLISHED
RELATIONSHIP WITH TAX MR LIKE.
HAVE. TFA THREE DOES FOR
EXAMPLE. THANK YOU QUESTIONS
FROM COMMITTEE. THANK YOU VERY.
LESS UNDER OUR PANEL. LET'S GO
TO POLLS LOOKING FOR ALL THE OF
REGULAR RESPECT FROM KERN
LICENSING AGES. COULD COUNT
APARTMENT OF FINANCE I'LL
PROVIDE A QUICK OVERVIEW- OF
THE ADMINISTRATION'S PLANS TO
CONSOLIDATE THE THREE CANNABIS
LICENSING ENTITIES INTO A
SINGLE DEPARTMENT. HAD LAST
MONTH IN THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
THE ADMINISTRATION PROPOSED ITS
PLAN TO CONSOLIDATE CANNABIS
REGULATORY FUNCTIONS IN THE
BUREAU CANNABIS CONTROL
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH AND
DEPARTMENT OF FOOD AND
AGRICULTURE INTO A SINGLE
DEPARTMENT OF CANADA'S CONTROL
UNDER THE BUSINESS CONSUMER
SERVICES HOUSING AGENCY BY JULY
TWENTY TWENTY ONE. AS YOU ALL
ARE THERE ESTABLISHING A LEAVE
CAMPUS MARKETING REGULATORY AND
MARK HAS REQUIRED US TO LEARN
IN OF ALL OF OVER TIME THANKS
TO THE INCREDIBLE WORK DONE
TODAY WE HAVE MADE TREMENDOUS
PROGRESS. READING A
CONSOLIDATED DEPARTMENT AS THE
NEXT STEP IN THIS EVOLUTION THE
OVER ARCHING GOALS OF THE
CONSOLIDATION IS TO SIMPLIFY
AND CENTRALIZED THE CAMPUS
REGULATORY STRUCTURE TO MAKE IT
SIMPLER AND MORE TRANSPARENT
AND MORE EFFECTIVE TO LEGALLY
AND SAFELY OPERATE OUT OF THIS
BUSINESS AND SECOND WE WANT TO
MAKE IT MORE DIFFICULT AND
COSTLY TO PARTICIPATE. IN THIS
INDUSTRY TO MORE OF. SMITH THE
WORK. AND EIGHT AND WE CREATED
GROUP'S DEMAND AS AN ADDRESS
VARIOUS OF THE CONSOLE THESE
INCLUDE STAFF CHANGES A TV
GROUP COMPLY AND FORCE.
LICENSING AND REYES. I. T. RE
BY INTO SERVE IN SO. THESE ARE
MEETING WEEKLY MY TIME A WEEK
TO MAKE SURE THE CONSOLIDATION
IS EXCEPT A SUCCESS WE'RE ALSO
IN THE PROCESS OF HIRING A
PROJECT MANAGER TO GUIDE THE
OVERALL CONSOLIDATION AFTER-
LEVERAGING BEST PRACTICES FROM
PRIOR RE ORGANIZATIONS. OUR
WORKING GROUPS ARE PRIORITIZING
THE DEVELOPMENT OF THE
STATUTORY CHANGES IN THE BUDGET
TO MAKE SURE THAT WE HAVE-
PROPOSALS FOR THE LEGISLATURE
TO CONSIDER THIS SPRING. AND WE
HAVE A SHARED INTEREST IN
MAKING SURE YOU ALL HAVE TIME
TO REVIEW IT AS WELL BUT WE
WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT IT'S A
THOROUGH PROPOSAL. A COUPLE OF
NOTES ABOUT. BUDGET PROPOSAL
YOU'RE LIKELY TO RECEIVE THIS
SPRING REGARDLESS OF THE
CONSOLIDATION THAT THREE
PROGRAMS WOULD HAVE SUBMITTED
BCP'S TO CONTINUE A SIGNIFICANT
AMOUNT OF LIMITED TERM
RESOURCES. TO ILLUSTRATE THAT
AN EXAMPLE IS IN THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET THE TOTAL BUDGET FOR ALL
THREE LICENSING ENTITIES IN
NINETEEN TWENTY IS A HUNDRED
AND FORTY TWO MILLION DOLLARS.
IF YOU LOOK AT THAT AND TWENTY
TWENTY ONE BE THE LIMITED TERM
FUNDING IT'S FIFTEEN MILLION
DOLLARS. SO THERE IS GOING TO
BE A SIGNIFICANT BC P.
REGARDLESS OF THE CONSOLIDATION
SO WHEN YOU SEE THE BUDGET
PROPOSAL THE SIX SPRING EXPECT
FOR. LARGE DOLLAR TIED IT NOT
SO MUCH THE SOLID ATION AFTER
BUT TO PRIOR WHEN TERM FUNDING.
TO MISSION YOU SIZE GAFFER
WINNIE TO BE CONSCIOUS THAT THE
OF LIFE ARE EXPECTED GROW OVER
THE YEAR AS THE MARKET MATURES
SO COSTS WILL LIKELY GO IN
THOSE YEARS AGAIN SOMETHING NOT
RELATED CONSOLIDATION BUT WE'LL
HAVE TO A FACTOR OPTICS OF
GROWTH- THAT CONCLUDES MY
COMMENTS AND AFTER MY
COLLEAGUES TO HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY SPEAKING HAPPENING
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS. THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON. GOOD AFTERNOON
CHAIRS AND MEMBERS THANK YOU
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO ADDRESS
YOU TODAY MY NAME IS LAURIE
AJAX ON THE CHIEF OF THE BUREAU
OF CANNABIS CONTROL- AS YOU
KNOW THE BUREAU REGULATE THE
DISTRIBUTORS TESTING LAB
RETAILERS MICRO BUSINESS
INTEMPERATE CANNABIS OF AUNTS
AND MY TESTIMONY IS GOING TO
GIVE YOU AN UPDATE A BRIEF
UPDATE ON WHERE WE ARE ON
LICENSE SCENE- EDUCATIONAL
EFFORTS ENFORCEMENT AND LOCAL
EQUITY GRANT. FOR THE BUREAU.
GETTING PEOPLE IN THE BUSINESS
IS IN THE TOP PRIORITY FOR ALL
THREE OF US AS MOST OF YOU KNOW
LAST YEAR WE TRANSITION FROM
TEMPORARY LICENSES TO
PROVISIONAL AN ANNUAL LICENSES.
TO DATE WE'VE ISSUED JUST OVER
TWENTY FOUR HUNDRED PROVISIONAL
AN ANNUAL LICENSES ACROSS THE
STATE WE'VE CONTINUED OUR
EDUCATIONAL EFFORTS BY
LAUNCHING A SEARCHABLE
FREQUENTLY ASKED QUESTIONS
DATABASE IN PROVIDING UPDATED
SPECIALIZED INFORMATIONAL
SHEETS FOR EACH LICENSE TYPE.
WE ALSO TAKE WE'VE ALL WE ARE
ALSO TAKING THE OPPORTUNITY TO
EDUCATE LICENSEES WALL
CONDUCTING SITE INSPECTIONS AT.
LICENSEES PROMISES. OF THE
BUREAU'S ESTABLISHED A LOCAL
LIAISON AND EQUITY UNIT TO
FOCUS ON PARTNERING WITH THE
LOCAL JURISDICTIONS AND WRITING
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE TO
APPLICANTS. WE PLAN TO INCREASE
OUR EDUCATIONAL OUTRAGE OVER
THE NEXT YEAR TO PROVIDE
APPLICANTS MORE OPPORTUNITIES
TO WORK ONE ON ONE WITH THE
BUREAU TO ANSWER QUESTIONS AND
TO PROVIDE STEP BY STEP
GUIDANCE TO THE LICENSE PROCESS.
I JUST RECENTLY THE BUREAU
ADOPTED EMERGENCY REGULATIONS
REQUIRING STOREFRONT RETAILERS
TO POST THEIR QUICK RESPONSE OR
Q. R. CODE. CERTIFICATE IN
STORE FRONT WINDOWS AND FOR
CANNABIS DELIVERY AND
TRANSPORTATION DRIVERS TO CARRY
IT WITH THEM. THE REGULATIONS
WERE DESIGNED TO HELP CONSUMERS
IDENTIFY LICENSE CANNABIS
RETAIL STORES ASSIST LAW
ENFORCEMENT AND SUPPORT THE
LEGAL CANNABIS MARKET WHERE
PRODUCTS SUCH AS FEET PRODUCTS.
FATE CARTRIDGES ARE ROUTINELY
TESTED TO PROTECT PUBLIC HEALTH
AND SAFETY. THE REGULATIONS
REQUIRE LICENSE RETAILER TO
POST THEIR UNIQUE Q. R. CODE IN
STORE FRONT WINDOWS OR NEAR
INTEREST ENTRANCE. TO EDUCATE
THE COULD. BE IMPORTANT FORTY
AND PER PURCHASING PRODUCTS
FROM THE LEGAL MARKET.
CONSUMERS CAN USE THEIR
SMARTPHONE CAMERA TO SCAN THE
QR CODE WHICH AUTOMATICALLY
LINKS TO THE BUREAU'S ONLINE
LICENSE SEARCH AND CONFIRMS THE
CANNABIS RETAILERS LICENSE
STATUS THE Q. R. CODE PROVIDES
A SIMPLE WAY FOR CONSUMERS TO
CONFIRM LICENSURE IMMEDIATELY
BEFORE ENTERING THE BUSINESS
AND WHEN THEY'RE DELIVERY ARISE
THUS HELPING CONSUMERS AVOID.
SCENES OF HIS FOR ILLEGAL
BUSINESSES IN ADDITION
REQUIRING DISTRIBUTORS TO CARRY
THE Q. R. CODES CERTIFICATE IN
THE TRANSPORT VEHICLE ESTES
FORSMAN IN DISTINGUISHING
BETWEEN LEGAL AND ILLEGAL
TRANSPORTATION OF CANNABIS
GOODS. THE PUBLIC CAN SUBMIT A
COMPLAINT THROUGH OUR ONLINE
COMPLAINT SYSTEM AND SINCE
TWENTY EIGHTEEN THE PURE PURE
OF RECEIVED- OVER ELEVEN
THOUSAND COMPLAINTS MANY OF
THESE COMPLAINTS ARE FOR
ILLEGAL ACTIVITY. TO ADDRESS
THIS ILLEGAL ACTIVITY AS A
FIRST STEP AFTER RECEIVING A
COMPLAINT THE BUREAU SENDS A
CEASE AND DESIST LETTER TO
EDUCATE THE BUSINESS ABOUT THE
NEED TO BE LICENSED AND TO
BRING THESE BUSINESS IT INTO
COMPLIANCE WITH THE LICENSING
REQUIREMENTS. IN ADDITION TO
THE SEASON DESIST LETTERS THE
BUREAU SEND LETTERS TO
LANDLORDS OF PROPERTIES WERE
ILLEGAL CANNABIS ACT MAYBE
BRING THESE LETTERS. IN ALL
CIVIL AND IT. PENALTY THAT
COULD BE IMPOSED ON THE LAST
LANDLORD FOR ALLOWING CRIMINAL
ACTIVITY ON THE PROPERTY. IF
THE ATTEMPTS TO BRING THE
UNLICENSED BUSINESSES ARE
UNSUCCESSFUL IN THAT YOU LEGAL
ACTIVITY CONTINUES THESE
COMPLAINTS ARE REFERRED FOR
INVESTIGATION. TO THE CANNABIS
ENFORCEMENT UNIT KNOWN AS SEE
YOU UNDER DEPARTMENT OF
CONSUMER AFFAIRS DIVISION
INVESTIGATIONS. SEE YOU IS
STAFFED WITH PEACE OFFICERS
HE'S PRIMARILY FOCUSED TO
CONDUCT CRIMINAL INVESTIGATIONS
TO SHUT DOWN ILLEGAL CANNABIS
MARKET. TO ACCOMPLISH THIS
MISSION SEE YOU WORKS
COLLABORATIVELY WITH OTHER
LOCAL AND STATE GOVERNMENT LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES. AND HAS
SERVED SIXTY THREE SEARCH IN
FISCAL YEAR NINETEEN TWENTY.
THE SEARCH WARRANT THAT
RESULTED IN THE SEIZURE OF
FORTY POUNDS AND WAS PROP
VALUED AT OR FOR. A HUNDRED AND
TWENTY ONE MILLION THE C.
THIRTY NINETY LEE- ARMS TEACHER
OVER FOUR HUNDRED THOUSAND CASH.
AND OF RETAILERS SELL COUNT IT
T. EIGHT. R. T. THE VAPING.
SINCE OCTOBER TWENTY NINETEEN
C. U. S. SEIZED APPROXIMATELY
EIGHTEEN THOUSAND COUNTERFEIT
FATE FOR CARTRIDGES FROM THE
UNLICENSED CANNABIS MARKET. IN
EARLY DECEMBER OF TWENTY
EIGHTEEN SEE YOU LET A TASK
FORCE IN THE CITY OF LOS
ANGELES WERE FORTY FIVE SEARCH
WARRANTS WERE SERVED AN
UNLICENSED KANITZ RETAILER
STORES. THIS YEAR OPERATION
RESULT IN A HUNDRED AND TWENTY
FIVE ADDRESS SEIZURE OF MORE
THAN TWO TONS CANNABIS IN
CANADA PER. MORE THAN. AND NOT
AND THIS OF A WEAPON EVEN ARE.
PLANE OF THE PRODUCT IS FROM
THE MAN AT WORK MR BY THE CAL
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH. OF
THOSE SAM TESTED 75% CONTAINED
UNDISCLOSED ADDITIVES SOME OF
THEM POTENTIALLY DANGEROUS AND
NEARLY ALL THE SAMPLES WERE
LABELED WITH CIGNA CANTLEY
LOWER OF THC. IN ADDITION TO
OUR ENFORCEMENT EFFORT THE
BUREAU IS CONTINUING WITH ITS
PUBLIC AWARENESS CAMPAIGN GET
HASH TAG WE USE WEISS TO
EDUCATE THE PUBLIC ABOUT THE
IMPORTANCE OF PURCHASING
CANDACE FROM LICENSE TAYLOR'S.
THE URGES CONSUMERS CHECK THE
LEGAL STATUS OF A LICENSE BY
GOING TO SEE A POT CHECK DOT
COM IN INCLUDES EXTENSIVE
OUTREACH TO EDUCATE CONSUMERS
ABOUT THE RISKS THIS. WITH AND
WHISPERED FROM THE LICENSE
BUSINESS. AND ALSO TO EDUCATE
UNLICENSED BUSINESSES THE NEEDS
TO GET LICENSED OR GET SHUT
DOWN. WE USE A THE OF METHOD
GET THE MESSAGE BUT INCLUDE
EXTENT DIGITAL PHONE MESSAGES.
PUBLIC ANNOUNCEMENTS MAILERS
AND BILLBOARDS. THIS CAMPAIGN
IS CREATED A BROAD COALITION OF
SUPPORT WITH NEARLY TWO HUNDRED
PARTNERS AND ON SHARE THE CAN.
LAST YEAR AND- WE'VE HAD OVER
TWELVE HUNDRED MEDIA MEDIA
ARTICLES THAT MENTION THE WEED
WISE CAMPAIGN AND SEVENTY
THOUSAND CLICK THROUGHS TO SEE
A PROJECT DOT COM FROM DIGITAL
ADVERTISEMENTS. IN CLOSING I
WANT TO PROVIDE YOU WITH A
BRIEF UPDATE ON THE LOCAL
EQUITY GRANT PROGRAM AS MOST OF
YOU KNOW THE CALIFORNIA
CANNABIS EQUITY ACT OF TWENTY
EIGHTEEN A STAB LIST BY SENATE
BILL TWELVE NINETY FOUR AND THE
BUDGET ACT OF TWENTY NINETEEN.
CREATED TEN MILLION DOLLARS FOR
THE ROAD TO FIND GRANT LOCAL
EQUITY PROGRAM. THE EQUITY
FUNDING PROVIDED FOR ASSISTANCE
TO LOCAL JURISDICTIONS
COMMERCIAL CANNABIS EQUITY
PROGRAMS THAT PROVIDE
ASSISTANCE TO LOCAL EQUITY OUT.
OR LOCAL EQUITY LICENSEES. ON
OCTOBER NINTH TWENTY NINETEEN
THE BUREAU ANNOUNCED IT AWARDED
TEN MILLION TO TEN LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS. AND IN SCHOOL
YEAR THIS FISCAL YEAR THE
BUREAU ALSO RECEIVED AN
ADDITIONAL FIFTEEN MILLION FOR
GRANTS TO LOCAL EQUITY PROGRAM-
WE HAVE CURRENTLY CONTRACTED
WITH THE- GOBIZ TO HANDLE THAT
PROCESS FOR US FOR THE FIFTEEN
MILLION AND APPLICATIONS ARE
CURRENTLY BEING ACCEPTED FOR
THE GRANT. AT IN THE BUREAU HAS
AS- A HIGHER STAFF THAT WILL BE
A RESOURCE FOR AND PROVIDE
ASSISTANCE TO EQUITY APPLICANTS
AND LOCAL EQUITY PROGRAM SENATE
IS AND THAT CONCLUDES MY TEMP
MY TESTIMONY THANK YOU. FOR YOU.
IN THE FACE WITH A MARKET. I
DON'T KNOW THAT IT'S GONNA
CHANGE ANYTHING ON WHAT THE
LEGAL MARKET IS CURRENTLY DOING
I DO THINK CONSOLIDATION MAKES
US MORE EFFECTIVE WHEN IT COMES
pBY YOU CAN SEE THE DATING ON
WHAT. ABOUT SEIZURES THROUGH A
NUMBER OF ABOUT THE- FOR THE
VAPE PENS THE CARTRIDGES YOU
GUYS SEE SOME THE CARTRIDGES
YOU SEE THAT JUST I JUST AROUND
EIGHTEEN THOUSAND THAT WAS IN
THIS YEAR AND TWENTY INTO ONLY
YEAH THIS. FISCAL YEAR WHAT'S
YOUR NUMBER. PART IS BEEN SOLD.
NINETY GUYS YOU GUYS TRACK AND
TRACE YOU EURO YOU'RE THOSE
NUMBERS TO WRITE FOR THE LEGAL
MARKET NOW THAT WE'VE GOT FOLKS
ON TRACK AND TRACE WE CAN PROP
AND I WOULD I WOULD DEFER TO
RICHER PARROTT FROM. IF WE HAVE
THAT INFORMATION AVAILABLE ON
HOW MANY CARTILAGES OUR GOAL I
WAS WONDERING IF WE SOLD TWO
HUNDRED THOUSAND CARDS AS WE
SEE IT TELL. VERY HARD TO AGE.
AND I GUESS MOREOVER DOES ABOUT
THE F. TO. EXIST TO COORDINATE-
ENFORCED NEGATIVITY'S BETWEEN
STATE LAW JURIST. HOW'S THAT
GOING. IT'S IS GOING WELL- WE
COORDINATED WITH THAT BIG- THAT
BIG MAJOR OPERATION WITH THE
CITY OF LOS ANGELES- AND
THEY'RE THE ONES HO ASSISTED
US WITH SERVING OVER HALF OF
THOSE FIVE. MORE HOW MAY BE.
AGENTS DO YOU HAVE THAT ARE
THERE PIECE OFF. IN YOUR BUREAU.
SEE YOU- CURRENTLY HAS FIFTY
THREE STAFF I DON'T BELIEVE ALL
OF THEM ARE ON SOME OF THAT
SITE MINISTRY OF STAFF RIGHT.
YEAH BUT THAT'S THAT'S THE
NUMBER OF THAT STAFF RIGHT.
CANNABIS AND FORCED ME UNIT SO
YES WILL BE JENNER'S AND EVEN I
GIVE YOU FORTY JUST TO CONDUCT
AN OPERATION OF THIS SIZE AND
STATURE- YOU GUYS DON'T HAVE
THE RESOURCES. TO CONDUCT THE
OPERATIONS ON YOUR OWN IS THAT
CORRECT. WHEN YOU SEE ON OUR
OWN- SO THE BUREAU UTILIZES
BECAUSE WE DON'T HAVE SWORN
PEACE OFFICERS WITHIN THE
BUREAU WE UTILIZE NON SWORN
INVESTIGATORS TO DO THE
ADMINISTRA FOR THE LICENSEES
AND THEN WE REFER ARE. BUT OUR
CRIMINAL COMPLAINTS CO BUT
THAT'S FOR LICENSEE SO FOR THE
ILLICIT MARKET THOSE
INVESTIGATIONS OBVIOUSLY YOU'RE
USING SWORN PERSONNEL NOT
INVESTIGATOR SO I'M SOME WIDE
DRILL DOWN DEEPER. INTO HOW
MANY INVESTIGATION YOU HAVE. IS
NOT A VERY BIG UNIT. TO INTO
THOSE TYPE OF FOR SOME
OPERATIONS. I GUESS ONE COULD
CONCLUDE THAT THERE THE
ENFORCEMENT ON LISTEN MARKET IS
VERY LIGHT. WHAT IS OR WHERE
THOSE US COORDINATING WITH THE
LOCAL JURISDICTION BECOMES
IMPERATIVE- TO MAKE SURE THAT
WE ARE PARTNERING UP WITH THE
LOCAL JURISDICTIONS TO ATTACK
THE ILLEGAL MARKET AND THAT'S
WITH THE EXPERTISE IS BASED NOT
WITH YOUR AGENCY. A LOT OF
OPERATIONS. I'M NOT SURE I
UNDERSTAND YOUR QUESTION. TO
THOSE INVESTIGATIONS YES THE
EXPERTISE IS PRIMARILY IN THOSE.
LOCAL AGENCIES THAT HAVE THE
EXPERTISE IN ILLICIT IN OUR IN
OUR CONTACTS PERIOD WAY SO THAT
WAS REALLY EXPERTISE LIES
VERSES LYING WITH CANNABIS
CONTROL OR EVEN DOJ FOR THAT
MATTER. CORRECT I MEAN
OBVIOUSLY OVER THE LAST COUPLE
YEARS THE STAFF AT SEE YOU OF
DEVELOPED. A LOT OF EXPERTISE
WHEN IT COMES TO- CANNABIS
ENFORCEMENT SO I WOULD SAY IT
IT IS ON BOTH SIDES BELOW THAT
X. IS THAT THAT'S MORE THE
LICENSING PART BEEN SAVING FOUR
PART. WITH THE AND I'M DONE
JUNE DOWN THE LIVE MARKET
SPECIFICALLY ON THAT. THAT
THAT'S REALLY THE BIG A HUNDRED
POUND GORILLA IN THE ROOM IS
LISTEN MARKET. SO. IT IS
SOMEONE I SPENT TEN YEARS
NARCOTICS. THE EXPERTISE LIES
THE LOCAL LEVEL IT IS NEVER. IN
THE STATE LEVEL OF ANY
SUBSTANTIAL AMOUNT EVER. SO I
GUESS DEFICIT IF WE'RE REALLY
GOING TO ATTACK THE LIST OF
MARKET. LOCALS HAVE TO PLAY
LEGAL PART OF IT BECAUSE THE
STATE CAN'T PLAY WHEN HE HAD TO
BE OUT BE ANY FOR DOJ. THAT WAS
LIMITED THEY RELIED ON LOCALS
HEAVILY. SO IT'S SO IT'S ALWAYS
BEEN THAT WAY WITH THESTATE
AND LIKE I SAID YOU CAN GO LOOK
AT THE EXPERTISE. TECHNICALS
INVESTIGATION WITH THE MARKET
WELL YOU'RE FOLLOWING SOMEONE
DOING SURVEILLANCE- MAKING
PURCHASES. YOU NEED THOSE FOLKS
DOING THIS OTHERWISE. THE
DENTURE MAKING THE LISTEN
MARKET IS INELIGIBLE. HI I JUST
WANNA MAKE ONE POINT A TO DO
THINK THAT- THROUGH SOME OF THE
LISTENING SESSIONS THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION DID WITH LOCALS
THROUGHOUT THE STATE. AND IT
OUT TO THAT LAW ENFORCEMENT
AGENCIES DO YOU SEE AS A
PARTNERSHIP IN A LOT OF WAYS
BECAUSE- THERE ARE THINGS THAT
ARE THAT THEY LACKED CLARITY ON
AND I THINK THE- SORT OF HEALTH.
NEXT YOU KNOW MAYBE SOMEONE WHO
IS OPERATE IN THE GRAY AREA
TODAY AND THEY'RE NOT SURE
WHETHER THEY SHOULD OR
SHOULDN'T FORCE WITH SO THEY
CERTAINLY DEFINITELY HAVE AN
IMPORTANT ROLE SO MAKING SURE
THAT WE KNOW WHO IS A LIST SAY
WHO IS LICENSED WHO AND HOW WE
SORT OF MOVED THAT NEEDLE SORT
OF MAKE SURE THAT WE HAVE WE'RE
PROVIDE OPPORTUNITIES TO
LICENSURE IN ADDITION TO
ENFORCING THE REAL BAD ACTORS
BECAUSE THE SYSTEM IS SO
SCREWED UP RIGHT NOW SO
AMBIGUOUS NO IT DOESN'T. THERE
ARE OTHER. THEY MADE CAN JUMP
IN WITH. CANNABIS CONTROL BUT
AS FAR AS THOSE AGENCIES DOING
THEIR OWN OPERATION. YOU BE
HARD PRESSED TO TELL ME AN
AGENCY THAT'S DONE IT'S IN THIS
CAN AMOUNT OF OPERATIONS ON THE
ILLICIT MARKET. BECAUSE IT'S
NOT IT'S NOT BEING DONE. SO
IT'S NOT THAT'S AFFECT. JUST A
FEW MORE QUESTIONS- DO LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS ARE SAID THAT ONE
HOW DO I THINK AUTHORITIES AND
FORCE AGAINST ILLICIT OPERATORS
AND LICENSE OPERATORS. MESSAGE
X. HOW THE LICENSING
AUTHORITIES AND FORCE AGAINST
ILLICIT OPERATORS AND LICENSE
OPERATORS SO- SO ALL THREE OF
US WORK TOGETHER WHEN IT COMES
TO LICENSE OPERATORS- WE ALL
HAVE STAFF THAT CONDUCT
INSPECTIONS INSPECTIONS MAKE
SURE THEY'RE COMPLYING LAW ON
IF THEY DON'T WE COORDINATING
THEIR IT TAKES ACTION THE LOT
WE HAVE ABILITY. TO PROVIDE
NOTICE TO COMPLY GIVE THEM AN
OPPORTUNITY TO COME INTO
COMPLIANCE IF IT'S SOMETHING
MUCH SERIES WE CAN SET FINE.
AND THAT IN SOME OF OUR LIFE
HE'S- OUR VERTICALLY IN A THE
THREE OF US WERE TOGETHER ARE
ENFORCEMENT TEAMS WERE EITHER-
TO DO THAT- AS IT RELATES TO
UNLICENSED COMPLAINTS- WE DO
TRY TO GET COMPLY ANSWER FIRST
WE ALWAYS WANT TO MAKE SURE
WE'RE LETTING PEOPLE HEY. A
TREMENDOUS AMOUNT. FIRST THAT
WE BASICALLY TRIAGE THESE
COMPLAINTS BY MAKING DOING IN A
OF THE BUREAU DOES THEIR FIRST
INVESTIGATION WERE MAKING SURE
THAT I COMPLAIN IS VALID WE
NOTIFY THAT- UNLICENSED
OPERATOR THAT. THEY'RE
OPERATING ILLEGALLY AND THEY
NEED THIS PIECE OR BECOME
LICENSED- IF THAT DOESN'T
HAPPEN AND WE REFER THAT TO THE
CANNABIS ENFORCEMENT UNIT AND
THEN THERE THEY WORK WITH.
JURISDICTIONS UP TO. THAT THERE
ARE ALSO WENT UNDERCOVER BUYS
AND THEN SERVING SEARCH
WARRANTS ON THOSE THAT ILLEGAL
ACTIVITY IT WAS THE BACKLOG. I
DON'T HAVE THAT NUMBER WITH ME
RIGHT NOW YOU KNOW THE COMPLETE
YOU GUYS HAVE I THINK WE'VE
REFERRED CLOSE TO TWENTY THREE
HUNDRED TO THE CANNABIS
ENFORCEMENT YOU AT OF TWO FROM
INCEPTION OF OUR RAM IN TWENTY
EIGHTEEN AND THEIR MUSCLES CAN.
THIS TO GET. MOST CASES THE WE
HAVE I DON'T HAVE THAT EXACT
NUMBER WITH ME BUT I CAN
CERTAINLY GET THAT INFORMATION
FOR YOU PLEASE WITH THIS IN
STRIDE THAT SO IT'S SO HERE
GOES AGAIN TO THE ACCOUNT
YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT FOR.
CONDUCT WAS OPERATIONS CORRECT.
THAT IS IN FORCE UNIT DOES A OF
THOSE INVESTIGATIONS THAT WERE
FOURTEEN TWO OF THEM THEY ARE
CONDUCTING SURVEILLANCE UNDER
COVER ACTIVITY IN MOST CASES-
GETTING THE SEARCH WARRANTS
WITH THE LAST ONE WE DID WITH
THE CITY OF LA IT WAS SPLIT
BETWEEN THE TWO AGENCIES TO GET
THAT FORTY FIVE OF WHEAT I
THINK FORTY FIVE SEARCH WARRANT
OF THREE DAY PERIOD. GOING ON
IN. THEY DO. COULD YOU SEE A ON
THERE YES THEY AND THEY WERE
WITH COULD YOU'RE GOOD YOUR
AGENCY HAVE DONE IT ON THEIR
OWN BY THEMSELVES. IN THE END
JUST THE BUREAU ITSELF WE DON'T
WE DON'T HAVE SWORN OFFICERS SO
WE HAVE TO RELY ON DIVISION
INVESTIGATIONS ARE CANNABIS FOR
FORCED ME UNIT TO DO THOSE
INVESTIGATIONS BUT YES THEY
COULD DO IT ON THEIR OWN.
INVESTIGATION INTO ON THEIR OWN
YES HOW MANY HOUSES DO THEY
HAVE SWORN OFFICERS. THEY
CURRENTLY HAVE FIFTY THREE-
STAFF RIGHT NOW AND NOT ALL
THOSE WRIST WORN OFF. YEAH I
DON'T HAVE THAT BREAKDOWN OF
HOW MANY SWORN BUT ALTHOUGH A
MAJORITY OF THEM ARE SWORN ALSO
IS FOR YOU. TO DO FORTY FIVE
SEARCH WARRANTS. YOU DON'T HAVE
THE RESOURCES TO DO THAT TO
SERVE WILL CIRCLE SEARCH
WARRANTS. YOU DON'T YOU DON'T
HAVE THE RESOURCES PERIOD. THIS
LOW. THIS IS THE NIGHT OKAY
HANDSOMELY ALONG THOSE LINES WE
WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT WE ARE
PARTNERING WITH YOU TO HELP A
SET YOU UP FOR SUCCESS AND SO I
THINK SIMILARLY- WHAT MIGHT WE
HELP ASSIST YOU WITH AN
INSURANCE YOU HAVE THE
FUNCTIONALITY OF THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF THE REALITIES
THAT WERE DEALT WITH AND
BECAUSE I THINK WE YOUR HEARING
IS SIGNIFICANT STRAIGHT I TO.
OUR QUIPPED BUT THE MAGNITUDE
SO VAST THAT WE ARE NOT ABLE TO
ACCOMMODATE THIS AND IF JUST
FOLLOW HE LET'S THAT TO WHICH
HE THIS BUDGET PROPOSAL WHICH
IS IN MAY THERE'S REST OF ALONG
WITH THE WITH THE- STATION OF.
WHAT DO YOU NEED. THAT WE CAN
IN THE CLIP YOU TO BE SIX. AS
THAT WE CAN ACCOMMODATE SOME
THE CONCERNS THAT HAVE BEEN
OUTLINED. AND I. UNDERSTAND THE
NEED TO FOR YOU TO ENGAGE WITH
THE BUDGET PROCESS- PRIOR TO
MAY SO WE CAN IDENTIFY THOSE
AREAS WHERE WE MIGHT NEED
ASSISTANCE. YEAH I THINK THE
ONLY OTHER THING I WOULD POINT
OUT IS THAT- IN STANDING UP ALL
THE SORT OF CANNABIS REGULATORY
PROGRAMS HAS BEEN A PROCESS AS
I THINK MANY OF YOU UP THERE
WHERE FEELING INVESTIGATED
DECISIONS IS QUITE A PROCESS IN
ITSELF- AND EACH YEAR WE'VE-
GOT THIS ISSUE IN LOOKING AT.
OUR ABILITY TO REASONABLY COME
FOR AND MAKE A REQUEST FOR
STAFF GIVEN THE NUMBER OF
POSITIONS WE FILL TO DATE-
AGAIN SO WE WILL CONTINUE TO DO
THAT AS WE GO INTO
CONSOLIDATION TO SEE WHAT COULD
REASONABLY JUSTIFY. I THINK THE
OTHER THING BUT WE HAVE ABOUT
WHEN WE'RE THINKING ABOUT
FORCED IN IS A PROCESS IN
ABILITY. ABOUT YOU KNOW I MEAN
TO PUT THOUSAND. OAKS OUT THERE
TODAY TO DOWN LIST ARE LADY
NEEDED A YEAR FROM NOW. AND THE-
WAS AT COST TO THE V. PAIRS.
THERE ARE THERE ARE THERE A LOT
OF COMPLICATED FACTORS IN
ADDITION OTHER LIFE. OP WITHIN
A JURY. YES NOT A SIMPLE OF THE
ISSUE I THANK EACH YEAR YOU AND
I AM I DON'T THINK WHICH I'M
TRYING TO MINIMIZE IT BUT I WAS
JUST SORT. THE CALL PATIENTS.
ARE ABOUT. WHEN THEY COME FOR
WIN. JUST THE NEED THAT WE HAVE
HEARD THE BILL FELL INTO. THAT
AND ALSO SORT OF LOOKING AT
WHAT CAN WE STAND THAT'S THE
AMOUNT ON. ALSO CUT. BUT I
THINK WITH THE- IN THE DESK.
THIS CAN CALIFORNIA BECAUSE OF
THIS. DE COME FROM THE ILLICIT
MARKET. THIS MAY ALL. AND THIS
ABOUT PUBLIC EXPECT THAT
GOVERNMENT US FOR THE PEER DO
SOMETHING IN RIGHT NOW WE NOT
DOING THAT WOULD ALSO AND ALSO
THE NEW IS NOT MUCH IN NEW WAS
BEFORE AND WE'RE STILL NOT
DOING ANYTHING IS STILL ISSUE
CAN HAPPEN ISSUE AND THEY'RE
SCARED THAT'S WITH NOT DOING AS
MUCH BUT WE STILL HAVE AN
OBLIGATION TO DO SO WITH THAT
YEAH RESOURCE THEY HAVEN'T. NOW
WE'RE MORE. SEE IN THE OTHER
THAT'S WILL BE BEING IS TO
UNDER ONE ROOF. BUT STILL YOU
NEED THE PARTLY WHY THERE'S NO
REASON TO COME OUT OF THE DARK
AND KEEP SELLING BECAUSE THAT
THE PENALTY. VISIBLE YOU'RE
FINE SIMULATOR EARLIER YOU KNOW
LISTEN MARKET STOP IT CHANGE IT
GET BETTER SEE A BUNCH OF
LETTERS BUT FROM DAIS IN A
LETTER. UNTIL SOMETHING ON. THE
BIG LAG TIME. SO IT'S WORTH IT
IN A BUSINESS SENSE TO KEEP
WHILE BEING. LAW BECAUSE IF.
YOU MAKING A TON OF MONEY. AND
THE RISK IS VERY LOW. BECAUSE
IT IS THE ONLY CASES THAT'S WE
WERE DOWN TO SO WE NEED THE
PROBLEM WITH THE VAPING PART.
AND THE INDUSTRY WANTS TO GET
RID OF BAD ACTORS TO. THEY'RE
PAYING TAXES FOR THIS. SO WE'RE
SEEING OUR HANSEL. WHEN WE GO
TO HEAD TOWARD NEXT TO- OTHER
PANELIST HEAR FROM THEM. GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIRS AND COMMITTEE
MEMBERS- THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO PRESENT TODAY.
MY NAME IS MARIN KLEIN AND I AM
THE ASSISTANT DEPUTY DIRECTOR
FOR THE CENTER FOR
ENVIRONMENTAL HEALTH THE MONEY
FACTOR CAN OF A SAFETY PROGRAM
ARM IN A PUBLIC HEALTH. IT IS
ONE OF THE THREE STATE ENOUGH
ORTIZ RESPONSIBLE FOR LICENSING
AND REGULATING CANNABIS
MANUFACTURERS. WE STRIVE TO
PROTECT PUBLIC HEALTH AND
SAFETY BY INSURING COMMERCIAL
CANNABIS MANUFACTURERS OPERATE
SAFE SANITARY WORKPLACES AND
FOLLOW GOOD MANUFACTURING
PRACTICES. TO PROUCE CANNABIS
PRODUCTS THAT MEET PRODUCT
GUIDELINES AND ARE PROPERLY
PACKAGE LABEL. THE DEPARTMENT
IN COLLABORATION WITH THE OTHER
TWO LICENSING AUTHORITIES
ADOPTED EMERGENCY REGULATIONS
HE TWENTY EIGHTEEN. AND THEN
THE I KNOW REGULATIONS INCH OF
TWENTY NINETEEN. SO THE
CANNABIS PRODUCTS. PROBABLY
LABEL CLUED IN ALL CAN UP IN A
TENT. THE UNIVERSE SOME. DOWN
TO FIND A PRODUCT. IS
CONTAINING CAMPUS AND INCLUDE
ALSO A LIST OF. RADIANCE SUB
THE ANSWER. GEN LABEL CANNOT
MAKE ON HEALTH. CONNIVING
CARTOON USED TO WORK CAN OR
FREE THAT ARE POPULAR YOU
PROPERLY POPULARLY USED TO
ADVERTISE TO CHILDREN. CANNABIS
AND CANNABIS PRODUCTS MUST BE
PACKAGE TEMPER EVIDENT CHILD
RESISTANT AND RESEALABLE. CITY
PH PROHIBITS THE MANUFACTURING
OF PRODUCTS THAT POSE A HIGHER
RISK FOR CARRYING FOOD BORNE
ILLNESSES. OR RISK TO THE
CONSUMERS SUCH AS PRODUCTS THAT
ARE NOT TO SHELVE STABLE. AND
ADDITIONALLY MANUFACTURERS MUST
FOLLOW EXTENSIVE GOOD
MANUFACTURING PRACTICES THIS
INCLUDES PRODUCT QUALITY PLANS
THAT ASSESS THE OVERALL
MANUFACTURING PROCESS SEES.
IDENTIFY AREAS OF POTENTIAL
RISK AND MITIGATION PLANS TO
ADDRESS THE RISKS. MASTER
MANUFACTURING PROTOCOLS THOSE
ARE THE STEP BY STEP PROCESS
SEES FOR CREATING THE FINISHED
PRODUCT IN BATCH PRODUCTION
RECORDS THE DETAIL THE
PRODUCTION PROCESS SEES AND
CONTROLS FOR EACH BATCH.
PRODUCTS THAT THAT ARE HERE TO
ALL THE REQUIREMENTS ARE
CONSIDERED ADULTERATED AND
MISBRANDEDAND THE DEPARTMENT
CAN EMBARK ON THE PRODUCTS. THE
DEPARTMENT CONTINUES TO WORK IN
CLOSE PARTNERSHIP AND CORRUPT
COOPERATION WITH THE OTHER TWO
STATE CANNABIS LICENSING
AUTHORITIES WE MEET REGULARLY
TO COORDINATE- REGULATIONS
AREAS OF OPERATIONAL
EFFICIENCIES COMMUNICATION AN
OUT REACH AND LICENSING. WE
ALSO WERE CLOSE. COLLABORATIVE
PLAY WITH THE LOCAL
JURISDICTION. AND THE
STAKEHOLDER GROUPS. THE
DEPARTMENT PARTICIPATED IN SOME
PANELS IN TRAINING TO SHARE
LESSONS LEARNED CLARIFY
REGULATION AND IDENTIFY TOOLS
TO ADDRESS COMPLIANCE. TO DATE
PUBLIC HEALTH HAS ISSUE NINE
HUNDRED AND NINETY ONE
MANUFACTURING LICENSES. OF
THOSE SEVEN HUNDRED AND FIFTY
EIGHT OUR PROVISIONAL LICENSES
AND TWO HUNDRED AND THIRTY
THREE OUR ANNUAL LICENSES. THE
DEPARTMENT CONTINUES TO WORK
CLOSELY WITH THE LICENSEES
HOLDING A PROVISIONAL LICENSE
IN THE LOCAL JURISDICTIONS TO
ENSURE THAT THESE BUSINESSES
TRANSITION INTO THE ANNUAL
LICENSE. THE DEPARTMENT
IMPLEMENTED ON ONLINE LICENSING
SYSTEM WHICH ALLOWS THE
LICENSEES TO SUMMIT ON
MANUFACTURING LICENSE
APPLICATION CHECK THE
APPLICATION STATUS AND MAKE
ONLINE PAYMENTS. THE PROGRAM
HAS BEEN RESPONDING TO INQUIRE
REYES AND COMPLAINTS FROM THE
INDUSTRY AND THE PUBLIC WE HAVE
MULTIPLE AVENUES FOR PEOPLE TO
CONTACT PUBLIC HEALTH WE HAVE A
TOLL FREE PHONE NUMBER WE HAVE
AN EMAIL ADDRESS WE HAVE AN
ONLINE COMPLAINT FORM. ALL
COMPLAINTS ARE REVIEW BY OUR
TEAM AND RESPOND AS QUICKLY. WE
RECOGNIZE THE KEY ELEMENT TO
COMPLIANCE IS ACCESS TO
INFORMATION AND TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE. THE DEPARTMENT'S
WEBSITE INCLUDES EXTENSIVE
MATERIAL FOR THE LICENSEES AND
THE PUBLIC SUCH AS REGULATORY
GUIDELINES. LICENSING
INSTRUCTIONS I LICENSE- SEARCH
TO WALL. AND FAQS BY TOPIC. OUR
LICENSING AND FEEL COMPLIANCE
TEAMS PROVIDE TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE TO LICENSEES TO
ENSURE THEY MEET THE FACILITY
REQUIREMENTS AND THE REGULATORY
MANDATES. CONTINUES TOOLS. AND
AVAILABLE ONLINE TO ALL OF OUR
LICENSEES. PART OF THE
REGULATORY PROGRAM ALSO
INCLUDES INFO COMPLIANCE AND
ENFORCEMENT TO ENSURE PRODUCT
SAFETY. THE DEPARTMENT HAS FIVE
REGIONAL OFFICES STAFF I
ENVIRONMENTAL SCIENTIST WHICH
CONDUCT ROUTINE INSPECTION OF
FACILITIES AND PROVIDE FACILITY.
OWNERS WITH NOTICES OF
VIOLATION TO KERR A TO. TIM THE
MANDATE REQUIRE. I OFFICE WITH
OTHER COUNT OFFICE. AT THE
STATE AND THE LOCAL LEVEL TO
CONDUCT INVESTIGATIONS ADDRESS
COMPLAINTS AND TAKE ANY
ENFORCEMENT ACTIONS THAT ARE
NEEDED. THIS APPROACH LEVERAGES
THE RESOURCE THIRTY SEVEN EACH
AGENCY. WE ARE COMMITTED TO
CONTINUING TO SUPPORT
BUSINESSES BY OFFERING GUIDANCE
AND TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE THANK
YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
SHARE THE ACTIVITIES OF PUBLIC
HEALTH. I'LL TURN IT OVER TO
RETURN NOW. GOOD AFTERNOON
CHAIRMAN COOPER GERMAN LOW
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE. MY
NAME'S RICHARD PARROTT I'M THE
DIRECTOR OF THE CAL CANNABIS
CULTIVATION LICENSING DIVISION
WITH THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT
OF FOOD AND AGRICULTURE THANK
YOU FOR HAVING ME HERE.
DEPARTMENT OF FOOD AND
AGRICULTURE IS RESPONSIBLE FOR
REGULATING CANNABIS CULTIVATION
ACROSS THE STATE WITH
CONSIDERATION GIVEN THE
ENVIRONMENTAL IMPACT OF THESE
GROSS UP. UNTIL COME AND
ENFORCEMENT. BERMAN OF FOOD AND
AGRICULTURE IS ALSO ESPONSIBLE
FOR ADMINISTERING. THE
CALIFORNIA CANNABIS TRACK AND
TRACE SYSTEM THE CONTRACT
COMMERCIAL CANVAS ACTIVITIES IN
THE STATE. THE TRUCK ENTRY
SYSTEM CONTAINS INFORMATION
FROM UNIQUE IDENTIFIERS THE
LICENSEES USE TO IDENTIFY
CANNABIS AND CANVAS PRODUCTS IN
THEIR POSSESSION. WE'RE PROUD
OF THE WORK WE'VE DONE SINCE
THE INCEPTION OF THE LICE
CAMPUS LICENSING IN CALIFORNIA
AND I'M GONNA GIVE YOU A FEW%
HIGHLIGHTS OF WHAT WE'VE BEEN
DOING. FOR OUR REGION EDUCATION
WHICH WE THINK IS THE KEY
FOUNDATION TO QUIT THE
REGULATED INDUSTRY FOR
SUCCESSFUL COMPLIANCE. DURING
TWENTY NINETEEN WE WERE PART OF
FIFTY FOUR EVENTS STATEWIDE.
SOME EXAMPLES ARE WORKSHOPS
WITH OUR PARTNER AGENCIES
DEPARTMENT OF FISH AND WILDLIFE
AND WATER BOARDS WERE ATTENDEES
CAN RECEIVE TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE WITH PERMITTING AND
STATE LICENSING WE'VE HELD
TRACK AND TRACE OVERVIEW
SESSIONS ACROSS THE STATE. CFA
LEADERSHIP ALONG WITH MY
COUNTERPARTS- SPEAK AT VARIOUS
CONFERENCES AND OTHER
ASSOCIATION MEETINGS. WE'VE
HELD WEBINARS WITH OUR LOCAL
POINT OF CONTACT EDUCATE THEM
ABOUT HER LIFE PRONTO. AND IT
IT OUR WEBSITE CONTAINS FOR
SHEETS TRAINING VIDIC VIDEOS
AND A LOT OF OTHER INFORMATION
FOR THE INDUSTRY. FOR ALL
MISSING WE CAN TO ISSUE A- AND
REGIONAL CULTIVATE LICENSES. AS
OF TODAY WE'VE ISSUED SEVEN
HUNDRED ANNUAL LICENSES. FOUR
THOUSAND TWO HUNDRED AND
SEVENTY EIGHT PROVISIONAL
LICENSES AND WE'VE APPROVED AN
NINE LICENSES WHICH ARE PENDING
PAYMENT. OUR COMPLIANCE WORK-
WE CONDUCT COMPLAINTS WORK
WITHIN THE LICENSE MARKET CFA
HAS STAFF THAT CONDUCT ROUTINE
COMPLIANCE INSPECTIONS OUT
LICENSE CULTIVATION SITES ROUTE
THE STATE. ADDITIONALLY WE'VE
LEVERAGES PARTNERSHIPS WITH THE
COUNTY AGRICULTURAL
COMMISSIONERS IN ABOUT FIFTEEN
DIFFERENT COUNTIES WE HAVE
CONTRACTS FOR THE AYE
COMMISSIONER STAFF TO CONDUCT
THE ROUTINE INSPECTIONS ON OUR
BEHALF. IT HELPS IS HOW MORE
BOOTS ON THE GROUND ACROSS THE
STATE THE AGRICULTURE
COMMISSIONERS ARE OUT IN THAT
AGRICULTURAL SPACE AND
CONDUCTING PESTICIDE AND USE
INSPECTIONS IN WILL- FIELD
WORKER SAFETY INSPECTIONS SO
WE'RE ABLE TO LEVERAGE THEIR-
BEING OUT IN THE OUT IN THE
FIELD AND THEY WERE WE PARTNER
WITH THEM. FOR TWENTY NINETEEN
THERE WAS A TOTAL OF SIXTY FOUR
HUNDRED AND SIXTY FIVE LICENSES
INSPECTED ACROSS THE STATE. WE
ALSO HAVE A COMPLAINT HOTLINE
FOR ANYONE TO CALL WITH
INFORMATION REGARDING SUSPECTS
SUSPECTED ILLICIT ACTIVITY FOR
ANY OTHER CONCERNS WE RECEIVED
AND WORK THROUGH FOUR HUNDRED
AND FIFTY COMPLAINTS IN TWENTY
NINETEEN. IN SOME INSTANCES THE
COMPLAINT WILL RESULT IN A SITE
VISIT BY CDFA AND IN SOME CASES
WE MAY REFER THE MATTER TO ONE
OF OUR STATE PARTNERS MEANING
TO PARTNER FISH AND WILDLIFE OR
THE COURTS OR TO A LOCAL LAW
ENFORCEMENT A AND C. DEPENDING
ON THE INFORMATION IS PROVIDED
IN THE COMPLAINT. AS OF TODAY
THERE'S A LESS THAN THIRTY THAT
ARE FORTY PLANTS ARE CURRENTLY
UNDER REVIEW. WITH REGARD TO
ELICIT. IN TWENTY NINETEEN
DEPARTMENT OF FOOD AND
AGRICULTURE PARTICIPATED IN ONE
HUNDRED AND FORTY SIX
ENFORCEMENT ACTIVITIES.
INCLUDING MORE THAN ONE HUNDRED
CRIMINAL SEARCH WARRANTS IN
COLLABORATION WITH STATE AND
LOCAL AGENCIES. IN THESE
INSTANCES THE PDF A WAS THERE
TO PROVIDE TECHNICAL EXPERTISE
ON THE SITE. AT WHERE THE
WARRANT WAS SERVED WERE
COLLECTING EVIDENCE FOR CIVIL
AND ADMINISTRATIVE PROCEEDINGS.
THEN WE ALSO PROVIDE A REPORT
FROM NATION TO LOCAL. ATTORNEYS
CASE AGENTS OR OF THE AG'S
OFFICE IF NECESSARY. WE ALSO
HAVE SEVEN ENFORCEMENT STAFF
DEDICATED TO PARTICIPATING IN
THE CAN OF CANNABIS ENFORCEMENT
PROGRAM WHICH WS FORMERLY THE
WATERSHED ENFORCEMENT TEAM.
THAT'S A PARTNERSHIP WITH
DEPARTMENT OF FISH AND WILDLIFE
AND WATER BOARDS TO COME TO
COMBAT THE ILLICIT MARKET
THAT'S A SEASONAL EFFORT THAT
STARTS WHEN THE OUTDOOR GROWING
SEASON REALLY RAMPS UP WE HAVE
ALSO BEGUN- IDENTIFYING WAYS TO
WORK IN PARTNERSHIP WITH THE
JOINT ENFORCEMENT STRIKE FORCE
THAT'S FOCUSED ON COMBATTING
THE UNDERGROUND ECONOMY. CFA IS
ALSO PARTICIPATED IN FOCUSED
OPERATIONS WITH THE CALIFORNIA
NATIONAL GUARD EFFORTS TO
SUPPORT LOCAL LAW ENFORCEMENT
AGENCIES IN MULTIPLE DAY
MULTIPLE WEREN'T OPERATIONS
TARGETING. ILLEGAL COMMERCIAL
CANNABIS CULTIVATION. WITH
pREGARD TO TRACK AND TRACE CFA
IS RESPONSIBLE FOR
ADMINISTRATION OF THE STATE'S
TRACK INTERESTPROGRAM THAT
USED BY ALL COMMERCIAL CANNABIS
LICENSEES BOTH PROVISIONAL AND
ANNUAL LICENSEES. THE SYSTEM IS
USED TO ENSURE THAT ALL
MOVEMENT OF CANNABIS IN
CANNABIS PRODUCTS IS ACCOUNTED
FOR. IT SERVES AS A RECEPTACLE
FOR AND RECORD RETENTION FOR
ALL LAB TEST RESULTS AND ALLOWS
FOR TRACKING A PRODUCT IN THE
EVENT OF A PUBLIC SAFETY ISSUE.
RIGHT NOW WE HAVE ABOUT A TWO
HUNDRED CREDENTIALS USED
CREDENTIALED USERS ACROSS THE
STATE OUT OF EIGHTY FIVE
HUNDRED LICENSEES THERE ARE
PEOPLE CONTINUING TO GET
CREDENTIALED EVERY DAY- ANY
LICENSEE THAT DOES. GET
CREDENTIALED FACES POTENTIAL
FINES AND OR EXPANSION OF THEIR
LICENSE- WE CONDUCT SOME
ACTIVITIES TOWARD THE END OF
LAST YEAR. ACTUALLY SUSPENDED
LICENSE ACROSS ALL THREE
AGENCIES. SOME THINGS ON THE
REASON FOR DEPARTMENT OF FOOD
AND AGRICULTURE WE'RE CURRENTLY
WORKING ON TO REGULATION
PACKAGES ONE IS FERN
APPELLATIONS OF ORIGIN PROGRAM
THAT'S- BY STATUTE REQUIRED TO
BE IN PLACE BY JANUARY FIRST
TWENTY TWENTY ONE. THAT WAS
RELEASED LAST WEEK AND AS WE
ARE CURRENTLY IN THE FORTY FIVE
DAY PUBLIC COMMENT PERIOD. SOON
TO FOLLOW WILL BE A REGULATION
PACKAGE TO CREATE A- COMPARABLE
ORGANIC PROGRAM FOR CANNABIS
THAT'S COMPARABLE TO THE
NATIONAL ORGANIC PROGRAM.
PROGRAM AS WELL TO BE
IMPLEMENTED BY JANUARY FIRST
TWENTY TWENTY ONE. FINALLY WE
ARE WE WILL BE AND BARKING ON
AN INDUSTRY AWARENESS CAMPAIGN
SOON- THAT'S- ALMOST LIKE A
COMPLIMENT TO THE PIER IS
CAMPAIGN ABOUT THE PUBLIC
CONSUMERS- BUYING FROM- LEGAL-
LICENSE CANNABIS SHOPS OURS
WILL BE TO ENCOURAGE OF THE-
UNLICENSED GROWERS TO COME INTO
THE MARKET TO WILL BE WORKING
ON THAT INDUSTRY AWARENESS
CAMPAIGN IN THE COMING MONTHS-
THAT CONCLUDES MY UPDATE I'M
HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS.
DO LOCAL HAVE ACCESS TO TRACK
AND TRACE. LOCALS A LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS DO BY STATUTE AND
WE'RE ACTUALLY WORKING ON A
PILOT PROJECT WITH ABOUT THREE
COUNTIES RIGHT NOW. TESTING OUT
SOME DATA GETTING SOME
FEEDBACK- AND SEEING HOW THAT
GOES SO THAT WE CAN THEN. SEE
HOW SEE WHAT WHAT THEY'RE
REALLY NEED FOR THAT DATA AND
THEN OVER IT UP TO OTHER COUNTY
SO WE ARE ENGAGED IN. CAR
CONVERSATIONS AND MEETINGS WITH
THREE COUNTIES RIGHT NOW. THE
FIRST. THIS WEEK'S YES THANK
YOU FOR THE THREE- LICENSING
AGENCIES- HOW MANY PERMANENT
LICENSE HAVE YOU GIVEN AND WHAT
IS PERCENT VERSUS YOUR PENDING
OR YOUR FOLKS THAT ARE WAITING
FOR PERMANENT SENSES I'M FOR
THE BUSINESSES- AND THEN OF THE
FOLKS THAT HAVE PERMANENT
LICENSES THREE AGENCIES WITH
THE CONSOLIDATION PROCESS. WHAT
HAPPENS TO GO THROUGH THE
PROCESS SURVEY. FINE. THE LIST
OF- SO WE HAVE. SO WHEN YU SAY
PERMANENT ARE YOU REFERRING TO
ANNUAL BECAUSE WE HAVE ANNUAL
OR PROVISIONAL THERE'S NO MORE
TEMPORARY LICENSE ANNUALS SO
SEVEN HUNDRED ANNUAL IS FORTY
TWO HUNDRED SEVENTY
PROVISIONALS- WE HAVE ABOUT
FIVE HUNDRED APPLICATIONS THAT
ARE OUT WAITED APPLICANTS TO
GIVE US MORE INFORMATION SO I
CAN RUN THE PERCENTAGES BUT IF
WE WERE BEING AROUND 20%
GETTING ANNUAL AS THE REST
GETTING REGIONALS AND I. I'M
EVEN WITH THE CONSOLIDATION I
DON'T ANYONE WOULD TO REUP WHY
CERTAIN GRANDFATHER'S THERE ARE
PEOPLE THERE ALL AND THEY'RE
ALL TWELVE MONTH LIFE. ONE
TRACKS WILL WERE. WE'LL HAVE
PRETTY TO READ THOSE LIGHT
BROTHER PROVISIONAL OR AN
ANNUAL AND SO CASES. WERE ALSO
CAN PER STATE IT WAS ONE CALL.
WISELY FOR THE- BUT IT SEEMS
LIKE A VERY HIGH NUMBER
PROVISIONALS FOR SPEAKING FOR
THE CDFA. IT'S MAINLY SEQUEL-
ISSUES AT THE- IN THE VARIOUS
COUNTIES WHERE THE APPLICANTS
OR THEIR LOCAL JURISDICTIONS
AREN'T QUITE COMPLETE WITH
THEIR SEQUEL PROCESS AND UNTIL
THAT TIME WERE NOT ABLE TO
ISSUE AN ANNUAL LICENSE SO
CLOSE LONG THEY KEEP RENEWING
EVERY YEAR THE- EXTENDED. FOR
EVER AND IS THAT PROVISIONAL OF
SUNSETS IN- AT THE END OF
WENTY TWENTY TWO. BECAUSE
SOMETIMES SICK WITH ISSUES
MIGHT TAKE FOR FIVE YEARS ONE
IS HUESO. OKAY SO JUST OKAY.
FOR PUBLIC HEALTH SIR TOTAL
LICENSE NUMBER IS A NINE
HUNDRED NINETY ONE
MANUFACTURING CANNABIS LICENSES
SEVEN HUNDRED AND FIFTY EIGHT
OF PROFESSIONALS TWO HUNDRED
AND THIRTY THREE OUR ANIMALS-
WE CURRENTLY HAVE NINE THAT WE
HAVE APPROVED THERE PENDING
PAYMENT WE HAVE A HUNDRED AND
FORTY SIX OCCASIONAL UPPER
REVIEW PRIME. AND THE RECENT
ALSO THE HIGH NUMBER OF
PROFESSIONALS IS BECAUSE MANY
OF THE LOCAL JURISDICTIONS ARE
STILL FINALIZING THE LOCAL
ORDINANCES SO UNTIL FINALIZED
AS LOCAL ORDINANCES LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS WOULD NOT
APPROVE. THE APPLICANTS FOR AN
ANNUAL LICENSE SAR OPTION WAS
TO GIVE THEM A PROVISIONAL ALL
OF THESE ARE- TWELVE MONTHS
LICENSES AND WE'RE IN THE
PROCESS OF. MOST OF OUR
RENEWALS ARE STARTING THIS
MONTH IN MARCH APRIL AND MAY
AND ALL OF THOSE ONCE THEIR
RENEWED TO THE NEW DEPARTMENT
AND THEY WERE JUST TRYING. YOUR
FOR THE BUREAU LIMóN OF OUR
LICENSES ARE PROFESSIONALS-
WE'RE AT ABOUT SEVENTY FIVE
ANNUALS IN THE NICK AND WE'VE
ISSUED JUST I THINK TWENTY FOUR
HUNDRED AND ONE LICENSE- FOR
US- IN SEQUEL- BUT IT'S ALSO
FOR LIKE OUR RETAILERS BECAUSE
THEY'RE- THERE ARE A LOT OF
THEM ARE STILL. GOING THROUGH
LIKE- PUBLIC COLE SAYS ARE
GOING TO THE LOCAL PROCESS THEY
MAY HAVE TO GO THROUGH BUILDING
AND PLANNING THEY MAY HAVE TO
GET A CONDITIONAL USE PERMIT.
SO A LOT OF THOSE ARE STE THE
LOCALS HAVE GIVEN APPROVAL FOR
THAT PROVISIONAL BUT THEY-
HAVEN'T FOR THE LOCAL PROCESS
WE DON'T HAVE APPROVAL TO ISSUE
THAT. ANNUAL SO. I THINK WORDS
OVER. JUST UNDER HUNDRED
PENDINE BUT- A LOT THAT THAT
EBBS AND FLOWS WE WERE ABLE IF
WE GET- TO GET FOLKS INTO
PROVISIONAL FAIRLY QUICKLY
WITHIN A COUPLE. ONCE THEY
APPLY FOR A LICENSE- AS LONG AS
THEY- QUALIFY. THANK YOU. LET'S
LOOK. SELECT THE- YEAH I WOULD
JUST LIKE TO SAY. A COUPLE
THINGS FIRST OF ALL I'M
THRILLED ABOUT THE
CONSOLIDATION BECAUSE IT'S A
WELCOME LOGICAL ADJUSTMENT THE
NEEDS TO TAKE PLACE AND I THINK
IT'S GOING TO HELP THE
CHALLENGE THAT WE FACE. THE
MONSTER THAT WE ARE TRYING TO
TACKLE IS THE- THE COMPETITION
TO LEGAL MARKET. UNFORTUNATELY
WE LIKE NOR THEIR STATE HAVE A
BIG DISADVANTAGE BECAUSE
BASICALLY FOR TWENTY YEARS WE
HAD A MARGINAL MARKET AND WE
HAD A MARKET THAT ALLOWED
PEOPLE TO. SKATE A KIND OF A
CONSEQUENCE AND SO WHEN WE
ADOPTED THE LEGAL FRAMEWORK OR
WHEN WE AND HAVE ATTEMPTED TO
ADOPT THE LEGAL FRAMEWORK THE
ONLY WAY. YOU'RE ABLE TO
COMPETE IN THAT NEW SPACE. AS
IF YOU HAVE SOME STICK I KNOW
IT DOESN'T MAKE ANYBODY FEEL
GOOD IN HERE BUT IT'S FACT AND
THE END OF THE STICK THAT WE
HAVE IS NOT INCARCERATION IT'S
MONEY. AND WHAT WE HAVE TO HAVE
IS IN A FORCE AND ORGANIZED A
PARTNERING AS- THE CHAIR WAS
TALKING ABOUT USING LOCAL
RESOURCES. THEY'RE GOOD THEY
KNOW HOW TO GET IT DONE BUT THE
PROBLEM IS TO. IS THE
ENFORCEMENT IS CIVIL VERSUS
CRIMINAL AND MOST LAW
ENFORCEMENT DON'T. AREN'T
COMFORTABLE IN THE CIVIL SPACE.
AND SO THAT'S PART OF THE
FRUSTRATION AND IT WE NEED TO
FIGURE THIS OUT. BECAUSE IF WE
DON'T. IT'S NOT GOING TO
CHANGE. AND I DON'T THINK WE
CAN TO STAY IN A LEGAL MARKET
UNLESS WE'RE HAVING- BUST AND I
MEAN BUST ENFORCEMENT EFFORT-
L. IT'S BEEN. VERY VERY FIRST
BUT THE COMPLY. IT'S VERY VERY
DIFFICULT COMPLEX. NOT SO MUCH.
IN THE ILLICIT MARKET AND I CAN
TELL YOU THIS IS HOW BAD IT IS
FOLKS I MEAN I COME FROM A
DISTRICT THAT HAS. SOME PRETTY
RURAL CIRCUMSTANCES I HAVE WHAT
COMMUNITY ALL I'M NOT GONNA
MENTION THEIR NAMES. BUT THEY
HAVE OVER TEN DISPENSED REASON
THEY'RE NOT EVEN A TEN
THOUSAND- POPULATION IN THEIR
COMMUNITY. DOES PEOPLE ARE NOT
AFRAID OF RUNNING THEIR
BUSINESS. AND IT'S A SHAME
ANOTHER- PART OF MY DISTRICT
WHICH IS A PRETTY RURAL AREA-
HAS ITS OWN POLICE DEPARTMENT
VERY SMALL- LESS THAN THIRTY
OFFICERS AND THERE'D FOR DOING
THEIR DARNDEST. TO TRY TO MAKE
A DENT IN THIS VERY LISTED
SPACE I GUESS WHAT THEY FOUND
IN THEIR COMMUNITY THE CHINESE
CARTEL. AND IT'S A MULTI
MILLION DOLLAR OPERATION GOING
ON. THIS IS A BAD FOLKS WE HAVE
A REAL IT'S ALARMING HOW BAD IT
IS. YET THE ENERGY TO GO AFTER
ENFORCEMENT I HOPE THAT THE
GOVERNOR AND THIS LEGISLATURE
WILL UNDERSTAND THE IMPORTANCE.
AND THE CRISIS IT'S A CRISIS
ALREADY IT'S NOT COMING IT'S
HERE. AND I DON'T KNOW HOW TO
MAKE INDISCRIMINATE LOUDER
OTHERS. SAY THAT WE'VE GOT TO
WORK ON THIS I MEAN. WE MADE A
PROPOSAL YEAR FOR THE TEN
MILLION DOLLARS. TOWARDS
ENFORCEMENT AND WHERE TO GO
TOWARDS. THE EQUITY. AND I'M
NOT AYING THAT IS NOT A
VALUABLE BUT INVESTMENT. BUT
NOT AT THE EXPENSE OF
ENFORCEMENT. AND I JUST NEEDED
TO VENTILATE SO I DON'T HAVE A
QUESTION TO ANY OF YOU I DON'T
HAVE A CRITICISM TO ANY OF YOU.
IT'S JUST DRIVE HIM CRAZY.
BECAUSE I'M A MORMON REPUBLICAN
AND FIGHTING FOR CANNABIS. I
MEAN THIS IS NOT A COMFORTABLE
SPACE FOR ME THEN REPUBLICAN
OKAY SOLVE STRIKE THREE. I'M
JUST TELLING YOU MY HEART
COULDN'T BE MORE INTO THIS
BECAUSE IT'S THE RIGHT THING TO
DO AND THIS EVEN IF IT'S ON
COMFORTABLE I'M NOT GOING AWAY.
AND IM HOPING THAT WE CAN
PENETRATE THE YEARS OF POWER.
BECAUSE I HAVE A WHISPER AND
I'M GONNA SCREAM AND MY
WHISPERS MUCH AS I CAN. UNTIL
WE ACTUALLY TAKE THIS SERIOUSLY
BECAUSE GOOD PEOPLE. ARE
GETTING THEIR **** WHACKED. AND
THEY'RE DOING THEIR BEST AND
IT'S NOT RIGHT THAT THIS. IS
THE TUITION THAT THE TRUST IS
BETRAYING THEM. BECAUSE WE ARE.
THIS IS A MILLION ECHOING. MR
LACKEYS. EFFORTS WITH RESPECT
TO- OF TO ENFORCEMENT AND LEGAL
OPERATORS AND SPECIFIC YOU
LAURIE ON THE- WITH THE BUREAU
OF CANNABIS CONTROL I
UNDERSTAND THAT- FOR EXAMPLE IT
TECHNOLOGY COMPANY WE MET HAVE
REMOVED THEIR LIGHT UNLICENSED
LISTINGS BUT I JUST KEEP CAME
UPON AS AN ADVERTISEMENT ON
YELP THAT IS SELLING THE- GIFT
CERTIFICATES ON THE WEBSITE OF
FOR ILLEGAL CANNABIS SHOPS- IT
HOW DO WE TACKLE THIS IN IS
THERE ANY ENGAGEMENT IN
EFFORTS- FROM YOUR VANTAGE
POINT ON HOW I UNDERSTAND THAT
WE'VE HAD THIS CONVERSATION
BEFORE WITH RESPECT TO WHACK A
MOLE BUT- WE- TO. ADDRESS THESE
ISSUES THAT WE CAN HELP GOOD
ACTORS AS WELL. YEAH WE GET A
LOT OF COMPLAINTS ON
ADVERTISEMENTS AND SO WE ARE
OBVIOUSLY RESPONDED THOSE BUT
WE ALSO PROACTIVELY ARE GOING
INTO THE DIFFERENT- ILLEGAL ON
THE INTERNET I'M SORRY INTERNET
PLATFORMS TO CHECK TO SEE OF
THEIR COMPLIANCE IF. OF PEOPLE
ARE DISPLAYING THEIR LICENSE
NUMBER THEN WE'RE CHECKING IT
WITH OUR LICENSE SEARCH TO MAKE
SURE IT MATCHES UP IN SOME
CASES IT FOR SEEN THINGS. THAT
DOESN'T LOOK LIKE IT'S A LEGAL
BUSINESS WE WILL REPORT THAT TO
THE INTERNET PLATFORM AND WE DO
EXPECT THEM TO- TO TAKE THAT
DOWN OR PROVIDE US MORE
INFORMATION OF WHY THEY THINK
IT'S LEGAL. AND WORST THIS A
LITTLE BIT MORE SUCCESS BY
ENGAGING THE INTERNET PLATFORM
WE'RE ALSO IN THE PROCESS OF
SETTING UP ADDITIONAL TOOLS FOR
THESE INTERNET PLATFORMS TO
AUTOMATICALLY CONNECT TO OUR
LICENSE SEARCH THROUGH AN API-
SO WE CAN PROVIDE THEM. IT'S A
LITTLE BIT EASIER IF THEY CAN
AUTOMATICALLY CONNECT INSTEAD
OF GOING LINE BY LINE- LOOKING
AT OUR LICENSE SEARCH TRYING TO
FIGURE THAT OUT SO I THINK-
WE'RE STARTING THAT PROCESS NOW
AND IF WE CAN'T GET COMPLIANCE
THEN. I THINK WE'RE LOOKING AT
OTHER TOOLS TO RAMP UP THE
ENFORCEMENT AND- PERHAPS LOOK
AT SOME FINES OR PENALTIES. IT
IN THE KNEE JERKS WORKING THAT
PLAN YELP A THEY BEEN. TO THE
ISSUES THAT WHEN YOU I'VE
BROUGHT ITTO THEIR ATTENTION.
I BECAUSE MOST OF THESE ARE
PENDING INVESTIGATIONS I CAN'T
TALK ABOUT. SPECIFIC INTERNET
PLATFORMS. BUT WE ARE ENGAGING
WITH THE INTERNET PLATFORMS
SURE AND PERHAPS MAYBE A
DIFFERENT QUESTION- ARE THERE
ANY OPPORTUNITIES OR MECHANISMS
THAT WE MIGHT BE ABLE TO ASSIST
YOU WITH A TO ENCOURAGE AND GET
A GREATER SENSE OF URGENCY WITH
RESPECT INTERNET PLATFORMS. I
THINK- I THINK WE'RE ALREADY
FINDING OUT JUST WORKING WITH
THEM ON FIDING OUT THERE
CERTAIN INFORMATION IN OUR
LICENSE SEARCH THAT WOULD BE
HELPFUL TO HIM FOR EXAMPLE WE
DON'T REQUIRE THAT PEOPLE PUT
ON THEIR LICENSE APPLICATION A
DBA AND MOST PEOPLE WHEN
THEY'RE ADVERTISING THEY'RE NOT
USING THEIR LEGAL BUSINESS NAME
THEY'RE USING A DBA. SO WE'RE
MAKING CHANGES TO MAKE THAT A
REQUIREMENT SO THAT CAN HELP
THEM SO I THINK WE'RE TRYING TO
WORK THROUGH THAT PROCESS BUT I
THINK ONCE THEY HAVE THE TOOLS
AND- I THINK THERE MAY BE
THINGS THAT WE- WOULD BE IT
WOULD BE HELPFUL TO US DOWN THE
ROAD I DON'T HAVE ANYTHING
SPECIFIC. RIGHT NOW BUT- I
WOULD CERTAINLY APPRECIATE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO BRING SOMETHING
FORWARD WHEN WE COME ACROSS IT.
AND I JUST WANT TO SAY WE ALSO
DO A LOT OF EVERY WE DO THE
SAME THING WITH THE BILLBOARD
COMPANIES AS WELL WE GET A LOT
OF COMPLAINTS ON BILLBOARDS
THAT ARE OUT OF COMPLIANCE. SO
NOT ONLY DO WE WORK WITH THE
LICENSEE WERE ALSO WORKING WITH
THE BILL FOR COMPANIES THAT IS
PUTTING UP THOSE BILLBOARDS TO
GET THEM TO REMOVE IT SO IT'S
ON THE SAME FRONT LIKE THE
INTERNET PLATFORMS AS WELL.
GREAT THANK YOU SO AND YOU'VE
ALWAYS BEEN VERY ACCESSIBLE-
ONE OF BEEF BROUGHT THIS TO
YOUR ATTENTION SO I KNOW THAT
YOU'LL BE FROM YOUR COMMITMENT
TO ENSURING THAT WE HAVE THE
REGULATED. A MARKET THAT'S RIFE
WITH RESPECT TO THESE PLATFORMS
SPECIFICALLY AND THEN FINALLY-
WITH RESPECT TO THE
CONSOLIDATION THEM WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE IF YOU
MIGHT. THE INDIVIDUALS THAT ARE
CURRENTLY ON THIS PANEL- HERE
TODAY. HOW DO YOU FOR C. THAN
CONSOLIDATION WITH RESPECT TO
THE PROGRAM WHAT. WHAT WHAT IS
THE PROGRAM'S THEN GO. WELL I
MEAN I A I DON'T KNOW EXACTLY
HOW TO ANSWER THAT QUESTION I
MEAN I THINK I GAVE SORT OF THE
OVER ARCHING GOALS OF WHAT
WE'RE TRYING TO ACHIEVE HERE
SORT OF A- SIMPLER MORE
EFFECTIVE SYSTEM AND- AT ONE
PLACE WHICH I THINK IS
SOMETHING WE'VE HEARD. FROM
INDUSTRY THE LOCAL GOVERNMENTS-
YOU KNOW EVEN THE LEGISLATURE I
THINK IN SOME WAY THOUGHT ONE
PLACE WOULD MAKE SENSE- THESE
WORKING GROUPS ARE WORKING
DILIGENTLY TO FIGURE OUT. YOU
KNOW WHAT MAKES SENSE- AND HOW
TO IMPLEMENT THIS ANY SORT OF
REORGANIZATION OR CONSOLIDATION
IS A SIGNIFICANT AMOUNT OF
EFFORT. JUST IF WE WERE GONNA
TAKE IT IS AND TRY TO PUT IT
INTO A DIFFERENT DEPARTMENT SO-
YOU KNOW I THINK THOSE THOSE
DETAILS WERE REALLY STILL
WORKING OUT AND WE LOOK FORWARD
TO SHARING THOSE WITH YOU IN
THE SPRING. BUT THE IDEA HERE
IS TO BUILD ON THE WORK THAT'S
BEEN DONE BY THESE PROGRAMS
BECAUSE I THINK AS YOU ALL KNOW
THAT THEIR WORK SHOULD BE
APPLAUDED THEY PUT A TREMENDOUS
AMOUNT OF EFFORT IN THE LAST
FEW YEARS STANDING UP- OF. THIS
MY FROM THANK AND I THINK
THAT'S WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO DO
IN THE CONSOLE SO NOTE NO
SPECIFICS BUT MORE TO COME I'M
WE RELEASE OUR BUDGET AND
TRAILER BILL PROPOSALS. OKAY SO
NO NO CLEAR ON WHERE THE
PROGRAMS OF THE FOUR WOULD GO
UNDER CONSOLIDATION. WHERE THE
WIFE WHERE WHERE WHERE THE
CONSOLIDATION AGO WHERE WHERE
THE FOR YOU WOULD BE AND HOW WE
WOULD BE PLACED IN THE THEY
SHOULD KNOW DIFFERENT COLOR.
THIRTY SO RIGHT WHERE WHERE DO
YOU ALL GO I WAS GONNA YEAH
HOGAN'S BUT WE'VE USED FOR
THEIR JOB WHERE DO YOU
INDIVIDUALLY GO YEAH I KNOW I
MEAN I THINK THAT'S A I THINK
THOSE DETAILS ARE STILL BEING
TO TALK A SAID THERE'S NO
ANSWER. YES RIGHT OKAY SO THERE
IS NO ANSWER BUT YOU'VE HAD
ESTABLISHED WORKING GROUPS
RIGHT RIGHT AND WHO WILL
CONSIST OF THESE WORKING
GROUPS- THE PEOPLE AT THIS
TABLE IN ADDITION TO THE MANY
OTHERS WITHIN EACH OF THESE
PROGRAMS THAT HAVE YOU KNOW.
INTIMATE KNOWLEDGE OF THE
ACTIVITIES THAT THEY'RE DOING
TODAY OKAY SO I THINK PART OF
THE CHALLENGE THAT EXISTS IS
SUCH THAT- THERE IS
CONSOLIDATION PROPOSED. WITH
RESPECT TO WHICH YOU WANT TO DO
ON ON THE FOR WITH THAT THE
FOUR OF YOU. AND YET YOU
REQUIRE LEGISLATIVE APPROVAL.
AND YET WE ARE NOT ENGAGED IN
THESE CONVERSATIONS WITH
RESPECT TO. OUR ANNOUNCED
STANDING ALL OF THE ISSUES THAT
HAVE BEEN ADDRESSED ABOUT HOW
TO HELP YOU BE SET COME
SUCCESSFUL HOW TO OPEN POWER
YOU WITH THE TOOLS NECESSARY TO
BECOME. SUCCESSFUL AND THEREIN
LIES I THINK PART OF THE
CHALLENGE THAT I HOPE THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION ALSO HERE. WHICH
IS THAT WE HAVE SIGNIFICANT
RESERVATIONS. ON WHAT IS
ACTUALLY OCCURRING. AND IF YOU
WORK JUST SIMPLY A SOLUTION
WITHIN THE ADMINISTRATION
TALKING AMONGST OURSELVES
WITHIN THE WITH THESE WORKING
GROUPS. AND NOT ALLOWING BROAD
STAKEHOLDER INPUT TO WE'VE
TRADITIONALLY HAD ON THE
DEPARTMENT OF CONSUMER AFFAIRS
WITH A WIDE VARIETY OF OTHER
ENTITIES. THAT WOULD NATURALLY
WHEN THE SUN SETS COME UP FOR
PUBLIC DISCUSSION. THERE MIGHT
OF THE CHALLENGE AND DID THE
FRICTION THAT WILL CONTINUE TO
OCCUR. SO AGAIN PART OF THE
QUESTION THEN IS HOW DO YOU
FORESEE. BROUGHT STAKEHOLDER
INPUT. TO BE INCORPORATED
WITHIN THESE WORKING GROUPS IF
YOU'RE JUST TALKING AMONGST
YOURSELVES WITH BY THE WAY I'LL
STILL NEEDS LEGISLATIVE.
APPROVAL I THINK THERE'S BEEN A
OT OF OUR REACH THAT PLACE
OVER THE FALL WITH YOU. GOING
OUT TO MEET WITH LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS- IN INDUSTRY FOLKS
TO GET THEIR INPUT- WHAT I. I
KNOW WE'VE HAD A FEW MEETINGS
WE ACTUALLY HAD A FAIRLY LARGE
MEETING IN NOVEMBER WITH
LEGISLATIVE STAFF TO TRY TO
GET- TAKEN AND PUT- TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE UNDERSTAND. SORT
OF YOU KNOW WHAT WHAT YOU ALL
WOULD LIKE TO SEE AND I HOPE
AND I HOPE TODAY WILL BE ABLE
TO HEAR SOME THOSE MORE
SPECIFIC THINGS YOU'D LIKE TO
SEE FROM THE CONSOLIDATION.
BECAUSE THAT'S ONE OF THE
THINGS THAT WE'RE TRYING TO GO
INTO IS WELL I DON'T THINK
WE'RE TRYING TO DO IT IN
ISOLATION- AND I THINK IN A
CONVERSATION. AT THE STAFF
LEVEL OF CERTAINLY BEEN OPEN TO
LET. IS HELP US UNDERSTAND YOU
KNOW. THAT MA'AM WOULD LIKE SEE
SO WE CAN. DO OUR BEST TO
INCORPORATE THOSE THINGS OR AT
LEAST TO BE ABLE TO EXPLAIN TO
YOU WHY WE COULDN'T DO THOSE
THINGS NOW- IN SO I KIND OF DO
I DO FEEL LIKE WE'RE TRYING TO.
YOU KNOW BE OPEN AND OUT THERE
AND- IS FAR AS THE DEVELOPMENTS
GOES I MEAN IT'S VERY SIMILAR
TO ALMOST ANYTHING THAT'S WHERE
DEVELOPED IS THERE'S A
DELIBERATIVE PROCESS AND- THAT
HAS TO TAKE PLACE AND THEN WE-
PLAN TO ENGAGE YOU ALL AS WE-
TYPICALLY. DO THROW. BUDGET
PROCESS WE HAVE HAD AND WE LOOK
FORWARD TO THOSE DISCUSSIONS
SO- I THINK YOU KNOW WHAT
UNFORTUNATELY I DON'T HAVE A
LOT OF DETAILS TO SHARE TODAY
BUT WE HAVE BEEN TAKING AN
EMPLOYEE HAVE BEEN HEARING FROM
FOLKS IF THERE ARE SPECIFIC
PROPOSALS OR IDEAS YOU ALL HAVE
THAT YOU'D LIKE TO SEE
INCORPORATED I'VE HEARD
ENFORCEMENTINCIDENT IN A
PRIORITY TODAY- THAT YOU KNOW
DOES THE TYPE THINGS THAT ARE
HELPFUL TO US AS WE GO INTO THE
DEVELOPMENT THIS EXTENT
POSSIBLE LIKE TO BE ABLE TO
INCORPORATE. SURE AND THEN JUST
PUT YOU PRIOR TO. THE PROPOSAL
WHICH IS. APPROXIMATELY MAY IS
THAT CORRECT WITH WHICH YOU.
LOOK LOOK LIKE THE TIME THAT.
AND CLEAR AT THIS OKAY SO TIME
IS UNCLEAR- BUT IT THE HERMES
AND CLEAR BUT THERE IS NO
MECHANISM AND NO SCHEDULE DATE
TO WHICH WE CAN HAVE AN
ADDITION. ADDITIONAL DIALOGUE
AMONGST THE LEGISLATIVE BRANCH.
AND OF THE MINISTRATIONS. NOT
AT THIS TIME OKAY SO A PART OF
THAT IT WOULD BEGIN AGAIN TO
HIGHLIGHT. THIS THIS CHALLENGE.
WE WANT TO BEST UTILIZE THE
OPPORTUNITY THAT WE HAVE WHICH
IS THAT OF THIS INFORMATION
HERE BUT ABSENT THAT WE HAVE NO
MECHANISM TO BE ABLE TO ENGAGE
WITH YOU. TO HELP HAVE THIS
COLLABORATIVE DIALOGUE TO WHICH
THEN YOU HAVE A PROPOSAL IN
ISOLATION OUTSIDE OF THE
LEGISLATIVE BRANCH AND YET
YOU'LL STILL COME TO US TO ASK
FOR APPROVAL. SO I'LL JUST SAY
IS THAT IS ONE GAUGE AND A STOP
TYLER. THE BILL SO WE'RE ON THE
SAME PAGE BECAUSE IT DOESN'T
GOOD TO. LOOK IT GOTCHA MOMENTS
WE WANT SET YOU UP FOR SUCCESS.
AND SIMILARLY WILL BE ABLE TO
BE RESPONSIVE TO THE CONCERT
SEE THAT WE ALSO EQUALLY RIGHT.
AS WELL. TOTAL AGREED AND WE
WANT. TO HEAR PROPOSED HAVE
THROUGH DISCUSS ON THIS. GREAT
THANK YOU BUT GETTING HERE A IN
THE MAY REVISED HELP
LEGISLATORS. INVITED OVER TO
MEET WITH YOU GUYS AT IT. SO
YOU GUYS ALL FOR THEM AS- BUT
LUCIUS LAUGHED IS A CRITICAL
PART OF IT. THE INVOLVED THE
GHOST. YOU PLAY HAD MORE
DISCUSSIONS WITH FOLKS OUTSIDE.
THIS BUILDING IN THE
GOVERNMENT. LOCAL GOVERNMENT
HOWEVER THEN INSTEAD OF SO.
WE'RE MARCHES HERE ALREADY. IF
YOU GUYS HAD NO I WHEN YOU'RE
COMING FORWARD TO WORK WITH
STAFF IT'S ALSO AND WE'RE AT
THE MAY REVISE IT COMES OUT
THAT'S NONE OF TIME. WE SHOULD
AMPLE TIME THIS IS NOT A
PROBLEM HAS BEEN GOING ON. YEAH
WE ALL THE BILL HERE BEALL
SPOKE ABOUT AD NAUSEAM. IT IS
SOME POINT WE'VE GOT A REALLY
PARTS PLEASE BUT- FAST WORK
WITH IT. NOT JUST ONE TIME LAST
NOVEMBER. SO WHAT THE PLANS
GOING FORWARD. TO GET IT TO US
ONTIME AND NOT AT A LATER DATE
AND HOW DO YOU PLAN ON WORKING
WITH STAFF FROM THE
LEGISLATURE'S MITCHELL SAID.
WE'RE PART A TRY AT. BUT LIKE I
SAID I THINK WE'RE WORKING
DILIGENTLY MOST OF US ARE IN
MEETINGS MULTIPLE TIMES A WEEK-
BUT BUT NOT NOT NOT WITH
LEGISLATIVE STAFF THE LESS THE
DEAL. THAT ARE CERTAINLY NOT
NIGHT WE DON'T BECAUSE WE DON'T
HAVE YOU KNOW. COHERENT DETAILS
CARE AT THIS POINT BUT I AM
OPEN AYE IT'S AN OPEN
INVITATION. WITH STAFF AT ANY
POINT IF THEY HAVE IDEAS ARE
CONSIDERATIONS TO REACH OUT-
CHASSIS AND LET LET US KNOW
ABOUT THOSE AND WE WOULD LOVE
TO HAVE THOSE DISCUSSIONS I
THINK TO BE HELPFUL ON THE WAY
FOR STEP TO BEING GAUGE EVEN
JUST. MAKING RECOMMENDATIONS
THAT WAY IT'S NOT ALL PILED OUT
OF THE IT. THAT'S WHAT MAKES IT
MORE DIFFICULT. I UNDERSTAND ON
A MORE QUESTIONS FROM THE
COMMITTEE. OKAY GO HEAD TO
CARTER THIRD PANEL. WHICH IS
LOVE PERSPECTIVE.
GOOD FOR YOU
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIRMAN
WAS THE COMMITTEE- MY NAME IS
CARE MARTINS AND I AM A SENIOR
LEGISLATIVE REPRESENTATIVE WITH
THE CALIFORNIA STATE
ASSOCIATION OF COUNTIES I ALSO
SERVE AS THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR
OF A NEWLY CREATED ORGANIZATION
THAT COUNTIES CREATED CALLED
THE CALIFORNIA- CANNABIS
AUTHORITY IT'S A JOINT POWERS
AUTHORITY MADE UP OF COUNTY
GOVERNMENTS THAT HAVE COME
TOGETHER TO PROVIDE IT TIONAL
TOOL FR LOCAL JURISDICTIONS
THAT ARE RIGHT IN CANNABIS.
FIRST I JUST WANT TO SAY THANK
YOU FOR HAVING THIS YEAR- I DO
THINK AT THE LOCAL LEVEL WE
SHARE A LOT OF THE FRUSTRATIONS
THAT I HEAR- COMING FROM YOU
AND WE ARE REALLY CRYING OUT
SCREAMING AT SOMETIME OR
PARTNERSHIP WITH STATE A LOT OF
AREAS AND OF THE- CALL HAVE AN
ANSWER. WHICH I'LL GET IN JUST
A WITH SUCH A PROP SIX FOUR AS
YOU KNOW WE ESSENTIALLY CREATED
A DUAL LICENSING SYSTEM AND WE
BY AND IT'S NOT PERFECT ALL SAY
BUT YOU IN ORDER TO BE FULLY
OPERATIONAL IN FORMULA IN
ADDITION TO A STATE LICENSE YOU
NEED A PERMIT WHAT. OTHER AND
WE FEEL THAT THE ALL THIS
ANTENNA LOCAL CONTROL- VERY
STRONG HE BECAUSE WELL THE
MAJORITY OF HEALTH ARE SO POOR-
I DON'T USE FOR A KING BED.
THIS IS ARE LOCATED HOW MANY OF
OUR OUR COMMUNITIES. AND REALLY
WHAT THE SIZE AND OF THE- ARE
IS REALLY A LOCAL AND IN SOME
CASES A SENSITIVE ISSUE WITH OF
DIVERSITY OF APPROACHES. AND
THOSE PROGRAMS AND APPROACHES
CONTINUE TO OF ALL THAT THE
CITY AND COUNTY LEVEL- AS VOTE
MORE MORE FOLKS COME ONLINE TO
REGULATE. AND JUST TO GIVE YOU
A QUICK SNAPSHOT OF THE
LANDSCAPING CALIFORNIA THERE
ABOUT A HUNDRED CITIES AND
TWENTY EIGHT COUNTIES
REGULATING THUS FAR SO THAT'S
ABOUT 20% OF CITIES AND NEARLY
50% OF COUNTIES. AND WHILE THIS
NUMBER MIGHT- SEEM LOW IN
REALITY IT REPRESENTS ABOUT
65270% OF THE POPULATION LIVING
IN A CITY OR COUNTY
JURISDICTION THAT REGULATES
CANNABIS SO WE'RE WORKING TO
GET. THAT NUMBER UP FOR THOSE
JURISDICTIONS THAT ARE
INTERESTED IN REGULATING BUT WE
NEED SOME ADDITIONAL TOOLS TO
DO THAT. REALLY THE IMPEDIMENT
TO REGULATION IS NOT SIMPLY AN
OBJECTION TO CANNABIS LIKE YOU
FROM THE STATE IT'S A LONG TIME.
IN A TO ITS PROBE. ZERO
ENVIRONMENT COMPLETE IMPACTS ON
OUR YOUTH IN OUR COMMUNITY IS
PUBLIC EDUCATION AND REALLY OUR
ULTIMATE GOAL WHICH WE SHARE
WITH THE STATE IS BRINGING
PEOPLE INTO THE RGULATED SPACE.
AND COME BACK ILLICIT MARKET
AND ENSURING THAT THE LEGAL
MARKET FLOURISHES- AND BUSINESS
IS THRIVING CALIFORNIA THAT IS
WHY PARTNERSHIP WITH THE STATE
SO CRITICAL ALL- SO. CAN BE
SUBSTANCE OF THESE COSTS BY ON
DEVELOPING THEIR OWN RESOURCES
THROUGH TAX MEASURES ON A AND
SHE REVENUE AT THE LOCAL LATE
LEVEL BUT AS WE'VE SEEN. HIGHER
RATES OF TAXATION COMPLEX
SYSTEMS OF REGULATION ARE
REALLY ARE AN IMPEDIMENT FOR
OPERATORS I NEED TO THE
REGULATED MARKET- LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS AND RESPONDED IN A
NUMBER OF CASES FROM THE COUNTY
PERSPECTIVE BY REDUCE. THAT
ACTS BURDEN IN CASE THE IN LIKE
COME COUNTY SO. OUR TAX FOR AIR
TO. MORE BROAD. TO BOTH SPACE.
A WAY THAT'S LEESBURG OPERATORS
WHILE GIVING- REALLY EVERYTHING
WE NEED TO COMBAT THE LIST OF
MARKET IS NOT AN EASY FEAT AS
WE'VE WE'VE ALL EXPERIENCE BUT-
ONE THING THAT WE'VE LEARNED
OVER THE LAST SEVERAL YEARS IN
OUR WORK- WITH- COUNTIES IS
THAT DATA IS REALLY AT THE
HEART OF THIS SYSTEM AND IT'S
VERY SPECIAL AND IMPORTANT TO
EFFECTIVE REGULATION AND
ENFORCEMENT. SO OVER THE LAST
COUPLE YEARS COUNTIES HAVE COME
TOGETHER TO BE PROACTIVE IN
WORK WITH ONE ANOTHER AND A AND
DEVELOP OUR JOINT POWERS
AUTHORITY- REALLY WITH THE
PURPOSE OF DEVELOPING AND
MANAGING A STATEWIDE DATA
PLATFORM NOW THIS IS BY NO
MEANS MEANT TO DUPLICATE THE
STATE'S TRACK AND TRACE SYSTEM
OTHER IT'S MEANT TO AGGREGATE
INFORMATION OUT THERE ANALYZE
AND PROVIDE- REAL TIME DATA TO
LOCAL JURISDICTIONS- THAT ARE
REGULATING USING MACHINE
LEARNING THAT HAS BUILT IN
ANALYTICS AND ALERTS CAN REALLY
HELP FOR GREATER TAX COMPLIANCE
AND REGULATION- AND WE CREATED
THIS ORGANIZATION FOR SEVERAL
REASONS AS I MENTIONED- LOCALS
HAVE. LIMITED RESOURCES IT'S A
FACT WE'RE DEALING WITH
HOMELESSNESS WE'RE DEALING WITH
AFFORDABLE HOUSING PRICES WERE
DEALING WITH A LOT ISSUE BUT
THE COMMUNITY IN A MAJORITY OF
CALIFORNIA HAS SPOKEN AND THEY
WANT LEGAL CAMPUS WE TRYING TO.
WRITER TAX COMPLIANCE FROM
BUSINESSES AND GETTING FOLKS
INTO THE REGULATED SPACE WE
ALSO NEED TO BUILD TRUST WITH
THE INDUSTRY- WHICH MEANS WE
HAVE TO EDUCATE YOUR ARE ON
LOCAL FOLKS ABOUT WHAT THE
INDUSTRY IS AND WHAT THEY'RE
DOING- AND THEN FOCUS OUR
COMPLIANCE EFFORTS NFORCEMENT
ON THOSE FOLKS THAT ARE REALLY
OUTSIDE OF THE BOUNDS OF
REGULATION IN IN THE ILLICIT
MARKET PLACE AND REALLY TO DO
THAT THE ONLY WAY TO DO THAT IS.
GOOD AND TEN IS CLOSED JONES ON.
A WE WANT TO HELP THEM THAT
FOR. AND CAL TO ACCESS FOR SIR.
WE HAVE A CONFLICT BETWEEN STE
AND LAW BUT THERE ARE OVER FIVE
HUNDRED BANKS CREDIT UNIONS IN
THE COUNTRY THAT ARE WORKING
WITH INDUSTRY BUT WHAT THEY
NEED. IS DATA DATA TO ENSURE
THAT EVERY DEPOSIT INTO THEIR
FINANCIAL INSTITUTION IS FROM A
LEGAL TRANSACTION AND THEY NEED
THAT FROM REGULATORS. AND WE AT
THE LOCAL LEVEL WITH OUR PLAN
WITH OUR PLATFORM AND IN
PARTNERSHIP WITH THE STATE HAVE
THE POTENTIAL TO DO THAT AND TO
MOVE THE DIAL THERE SO THAT'S
REALLY ALL TO MY GOAL. OF THE
ORGANIZATION BUT UNFORTUNATELY-
WE HAVE NOT HAD THE PARTNERSHIP
THAT WE'D LIKE TO SEE YOU WITH
OUR STATE REGULATORY PARTNERS
IN A NUMBER OF AREAS YES BUT IN
THIS SPECIFIC AREA OF SHARING
DATA. NO AFTER REPEATED
REQUESTS. FOR INFORMATION OUR
CALL SO GOING ON ANSWERED THERE
IS A PILOT PROGRAM THAT'S
PENDING BUT FROM OUR- MEMBERS
PERSPECTIVE IT'S INADEQUATE
IT'S STATIC REPORTS THAT DON'T
PROVIDE THE REAL TIME
INFORMATION THAT WE NEED. WITH
OUR LOCAL LAW ENFORCEMENT
PARTNERS PARTNERING WITH THE
STATE TO GO AFTER THE FOLKS
THAT WE REALLY NEED TO FOCUS
OUR ATTENTION ON. HEARD FROM A
NUMBER OF FOLKS AT THE LOCAL
LEVEL AND THEIR OPERATORS THAT
THERE'S A LOT OF FRUSTRATION
BECAUSE OUR COMPLIANCE EFFORTS
ARE FOCUSED ON THOSE THAT MIGHT
NOT HAVE ONE BUILDING PERMIT.
BUT THE LICENSE FULLY LICENSED
ROUTE SORT OF THE ALL THE OTHER
ENTITIES IN APARTMENTS. WHILE
THEIR NEIGHBOR GOES FORTH AND-
ONE FOOT OUT THE DOOR AND IS
REALLY EITHER. PRODUCT OR NOT
WITHIN THE BOUNDS OF REGULATION
AT ALL AND THE ONLY WAY WE CAN
REALLY PRIORITIZE EFFORT IS
HAVING. TOUR DATA. OUR AND FOR
ACCESS ISSUE SAY. THE TRACK AND
TRACE. THE STATE A MESS OR TO
AMOUNT OF RE IN THIS PRO. AND
IN ORDER FOR TO BE YOU AND IF
IT NAY TO BE SHE AMONG SMALL
TO. LEVELS OF KERR WITH THE-
GOVERNOR PER. PROPOSAL FOR
CONSOLIDATION WE DO THINK THAT
THERE IS AN ABILITY NOT ONLY
TO. LOOK AT HOW ARE REGULATORY
PROGRAM AT BOTH THE STATE AND
THE LEVEL IS STRUCTURED BUT TO
IMPROVE THAT PARTNERSHIP AND
CREATE EFFICIENCIES AND GET
MORE FOLKS. ARE INTO THE
REGULATED SPACE AND WE MUST DO
THIS BY EMBRACING TECHNOLOGY
CONNECTING BOTH LOCAL AND STATE
SETS OF DATA- AND ALSO WILL BE
AN INNOVATIVE- CREATING
WEBINARS AND FACT SHEETS AND
HOT LINE NUMBERS IS IMPORTANT
BUT THAT'S NOT THE WAY WE'RE
GOING TO TACKLE THE ILLICIT
MARKET PLACE THE ONLY WAY WE'RE
GOING TO DO THAT. IS BY A TRUE
PARTNERSHIP BETWEEN THE- AND-
HELLO WELL AN ACCESS TO
INFORMATION THAT LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS- A LEGAL. RIGHT SEE.
WE DO BELIEVE SHIP IN. EIGHT
BEAR AND WE ARE MORE THAN
WILLING TO STEP UP AND WORK OUR
STATE RAY. AGENCIES AND ALSO BE
PART OF THESE CON. THAT WE'RE
NOT BEEN CALLED TO ANY OF THE
TO TALK ABOUT CAN. AND LOW
GOVERNMENT ARE REALLY A
CRITICAL COMPONENT TO THIS
ESPECIALLY GIVEN THE VARIATION
OF PROGRAMS WE HAVE ACROSS THE
STATE ONE OF THE OTHER COOL. OF
ON THE CALIFORNIA AT THE WILL
BE WAS GET FOLKS TOGETHER AT
THE LOCAL LEVEL TO TALK ABOUT.
BEST PRACTICES AND WE HELP TO
SYNTHESIZE THOSE. THOSE PROGRAM
EXCUSE MAKING IT EASY FOR A- TO
ENTER INTO THE REGULATOR SPACE
BUT ALSO PRESERVING SO THAT
WILL VERY. AND A LOCAL ROLE AND
OF SORT OF THE BOUNDS OF WHAT
REGULATE. I'M JUST THANK YOU
FOR THE ARE. TO MY COM A I DO
SEE THAT THERE. ARE SINCE. TO
HAVE THIS. IS TO GET IT OUT IN
THE- WE ALL CAN DO BETTER WE
ALL HAVE TO DO BETTER. AND
WE'RE MORE THAN INTO UP AND IT
AND DO THE WORK. YOU. AFTER. IN
THIS OF THE ILLICIT MARKET MY
NAME IS CHARLES HARBIN
LEGISLATIVE REPRESENTATIVE WITH
LEAGUE OF CALIFORNIA CITIES-
IT'S BEEN STATED BEFORE BUT I
JUST WANT TO REITERATE AT THE
OUTSET THAT- THE LEAGUE IS
NEITHER PRO NOR ANTI CANNABIS-
AND OVER THE LAST SEVERAL YEARS
OF COURSE CITIES HAVE MADE
CLEAR THE IMPORTANCE OF
SAFEGUARDING THEIR LOOK TORY
AUTHORITY HOW TO DECIDE WHETHER
AND TYPE OF COMMERCIAL AND THIS
IS APPROPRIATE FOR COMMUNITIES
AT THE END OF THE DAY CITIES
WHAT- SIMILAR TO WHAT. THE
SMARTS AND TALK TO WE WANT TO
BE IN PARTNERSHIP WITH THE
STATE- AND HELPING TO SHAPE
LOCALIZED MARKETPLACE
COORDINATE ON STRATEGIES THAT
PROACTIVELY WORK TOWARD READING
THE ILLICIT MARKET AND OF
COURSE MAINTAIN THE OPPORTUNITY
FOR THOSE CITIES WHO CHOOSE TO
AUTHORIZE COMMERCIAL ACTIVITY
TO IMPLEMENT SCHEMES THAT NOT
ONLY GENERATE REVENUE AND I WAS
WITHIN THE COMMUNITY I'M SURE
SAFETY LEGIT HE- REGULAR.
THOUGHT TO THIS I WAS A POOR
FOR THE CAN. ALL COLLABORATION
ON MORE DIFFICULT I WILL WHEN
IT COMES TO THE FORMATION OF A
NEW DEPARTMENT- INSTEAD OF A
BUREAU WELL WE OBVIOUSLY HAVE
YET TO SEE ANY DETAILS AS TO
WHAT IS ENVISIONED WE ARE UP TO
THINK ABOUT THE OVERALL CONCEPT
OF ESTABLISHING WHAT WE
CONSIDER TO BE A ONE STOP SHOP
WE HOPE TO BE A ONE STOP SHOP
FOR ALL OF CALIFORNIAS MARSHALL
CANNABIS RELATED MATTER. RISING
THE END NO NOT TO BEAT A DEAD
HORSE BUT THE OVER ARCHING
THEME OF MY PRELIMINARY
CONVERSATIONS WITH- SOME OF OUR
LOCAL OFFICIALS ON WHAT WOULD
BE MOST HELPFUL TO CITIES IS
COURSE INCREASED EMPHASIS ON
AND MEN TAKE EARLY AS PERTAINS
TO THE ILLICIT MARKET PLACE. SO
TAKE IN THE SIZE YOU WITH I
SINCE OPERATORS OF FOR INSTANCE
TO ENGAGE IN MULTIPLE TYPES OF
COMMERCE CITY MANUFACTURING. A
CALL. AND INCREDIBLY DE. WHEN
YOU HAVE DEAL WITH THREE
DISTINCT AND SEPARATE LICENSING
AUTHORITIES TO ADDRESS THE
ACTIVITY OF A SINGLE OPERATOR.
WERE CALLED IN EFFORTS TO
COORDINATE- LIKE IT'S THAT ARE
MADE VERY DIFFICULT. ENSURING
THAT COMMUNICATION STRUCTURES
IN PLACE TO SWIFTLY ADDRESSED
THE QUESTIONS AND CONCERNS OF
CITIES WHO ARE EARNESTLY TRYING
TO GO THROUGH THE PROPER
CHANNELS. TO RID OF PERSISTENT
LEGAL ACTIVITY IS PARAMOUNT IN
THE FOURTH COME SOLID ATION.
RELATEDLY GIVEN THE REALITY AT
LEGALWAS PRODUCTS INTENDED FOR
ADULTS INEVITABLY FIND THEIR
WAY INTO THE HANDS OF
ADOLESCENCE. THERE IS GROWING
CONCERN OVER THE PROLIFERATION
OF ACCESS TO AN INCREASED USE.
CANNABIS UNDER AGE PER. S.
CITIES LIKE TO SEE SOME SORT OF
LOCAL ENFORCEMENT DIVISION-
THAT WOULD NOT ONLY HELP TARGET
UNLICENSED ACTIVITY BUT WOULD
ALSO PRO ACTIVELY WORKED TO
HELP PREVENT AND TO TURN THESE
LEGALIZED ADULT. PRODUCTS FROM
BEING ACCESSED BY MINORS. CITY
OFFICIALS THERE BY NOTE THAT
THERE REMAINS A WIDESPREAD NEED
FOR ROBUST EDUCATION EFFORTS
THAT FOCUS ON K. THROUGH TWELVE
SCHOOLS. AND OF COURSE THE
PARENTS OF STUDENTS ON THE
POTENTIALLY HARMFUL PHYSICAL.
AND PSYCHOLOGICAL EFFECTS THAT
CANNABIS CAN PRODUCE ON YOUTH.
A CITIES WOULD ENCOURAGE THE
NEWLY CONSOLIDATED THE ENOUGH
CAN CONTROL. YOUR TAKE JACK'S
REGARDLESS OF EDUCATIONAL
EFFORTS THAT ARE ALREADY BEING
MADE AT THE LOCAL LEVEL. LIKE
WISE- CITIES AGAIN NEED MORE
TOOLS AND RESOURCES TO PROPERLY
ENFORCE AGAINST ILLICIT
ACTIVITY THEMSELVES. WHILE IT
MIGHT NOT DIRECTLY RELATE TO
THE PROPOSED CONSOLIDATION
HELPFUL MECHANISMS FOR LOCALS-
COULD INCLUDE OF COURSE EXPRESS
AUTHORIZATION FOR CITY
ATTORNEYS TO BRING UNFAIR
COMPETITION LAWSUITS AGAINST
UNLICENSED OPERATORS. THIS OF
COURSE COULD LEAD TO
DISGORGEMENT OF PROFITS AND OR
INJUNCTIVE RELIEF CEASE
OPERATIONS ALSO THE ABILITY FOR
CITIES TO SEIZE PRODUCT FROM
UNLICENSED OPERATORS MIGHT ALSO.
WITH THE STORE PASS. IT TAKES
ACTION AT PRESENT CITIES CAN
ONLY PLACE A DEAD BOLT ON THE
DOOR OF ILLEGAL BUSINESS FOR
INSTANCE- BUT OPERATORS ARE
OFTEN ABLE TO PROMPTLY REMOVED-
THIS ITEM AND RELOCATE THEIR
PRODUCT TO A DIFFERENT ILLICIT
MARKET OUT. THE BOTTOM LINE
UNLESS AND UNTIL CITIES GET THE
PROPER RESOURCES AND TOOLS TO
CONDUCT MEANINGFUL ENFORCEMENT
AGAINST ILLEGAL OPERATORS. IT
REMAINS INCUMBENT UPON THE
STATE TO BEEF UP IF IT'S
ENFORCEMENT CAPACITY IDEALLY
WITHIN THE NEWLY ESTABLISHED
DEPARTMENT CANNABIS CONTROL.
SECOND WITHIN THIS NEW
DEPARTMENT CITIES COULD BENEFIT
FROM SORT OF A LOCAL DIVISION A
LOCAL JURISDICTION DIVISION OF
SORTS WHICH WOULD IDEALLY
COMPRISE. PERSONNEL DEDICATED
TO ASSIST WITH A VARIETY OF
REQUEST ENFORCEMENT OR
OTHERWISE THAT ARE SPECIFIC TO
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS. I FOR
INSTANCE- THE CITY AREA- WANTS
TO ENSURE THAT LOCAL OPERATORS
THEY ARE COMPLYING WITH MINIMUM
REQUIRED BUFFER ZONE. BETWEEN
THEIR CANNABIS BUSINESSES AND
NEIGHBORHOOD SCHOOLS AND OUR
FAMILY HOME DAY CARE CENTERS IN
THIS CASE THERE WOULD BE
DEDICATED STAFF WITHIN THE
DEPARTMENT OF CAMPS CONTROLLED.
SERVE AS A LIAISON FOR THE OFF
PRESENT CITY AND BE ABLE TO
COORDINATE WITH OTHER
DEPARTMENTS. PRESS IS CHILD
CARE LICENSING DIVISION TO
ASSIST WITH SUCH A REQUEST. A
CITIES OF NOTED INSTANCES WHERE
THEY HAVE MULTIPLE PHONE CALLS
AND TRYING TO FIND THE RIGHT
YOU CAN ASSIST THEM ONLY TO
HAVE. QUEST EITHER IGNORED OR
RESPONDED TO IN A PROMOTES
FRUSTRATION PART OF LOCALS NON
ANOTHER EXAMPLE HERE THE CITY
OF SACRAMENTO JUST LAST WEEK.
AND OPERATE. I FOR A POLITE
THAT DID NOT CONDUCT BUSINESS
DURING THE REVIEW PERIOD-
DISREGARDED CITIES REQUEST. THE
CLINTON HI A LOCAL LICENSE NOT
WITHSTANDING WHILE THE LATER
ULTIMATE RISK A PER ALLIES FROM
THE STATE WHO INDICATED THE
DESPITE BEING. BY CITY OF THE
DEAD LOCAL. IS THAT. RIGHT THE-
ON THIS ON THE RIGHT TO THE
TERM IN AB TAKE ACTION OF THAT.
IN THE MEAN CITIES LEFT THE AN
OP. THAT HAS NOT AND WILL
RECEIVE A APPROVE BUT CAN
CONTINUE I ANY BECAUSE HAS A
STATE A LIES. SO TO HELP SOME
OF THESE ISSUES THAT SHOULD BE
VERY CLEARLY OUTLINED AS TO WHO
HAS THE AUTHORITY TO TAKE
ACTION UNDER CERTAIN
CIRCUMSTANCES THE LOCAL
JURISDICTION OR THE STATE. AND
IF IT IS THE LOCALS WHAT ACTION
THEY CAN TAKE AND WHEN THEY ARE
ALLOWED TO ACT. FINALLY ALL
COMMERCIAL CANNABIS RELATED
GRANTS SHOULD BE MADE AVAILABLE
IN ONE PLACE. A SINCE
LEGALIZATION THERE BEEN CAMPUS
GRANT OPPORTUNITY
OPPORTUNITIES- THAT HAVE BEEN
POSTED WITHIN DEPARTMENT PUBLIC
HEALTH GO VISIT CETERA- FOR
CITIES IT'S REALLY IMPORTANT
THAT ALL GRANT FUNDING WHETHER
INTENDED. FOR LOCAL ENFORCEMENT
EQUITY PROGRAM. ORDNANCE
CREATION OR ANY OTHER FORM OF
IMPLEMENTATION BE MADE
AVAILABLE IN A CENTRAL
LOCATION. FOR EASE OF ACCESS BY
ALL PERSONS IN THIS FUNDING
OPPORTUNITIES. NOW THE FOR WANT
CONSIDERATIONS AYE AYE LISTED
ARE REALLY JUST A SMALL SAMPLE
OF SOME PRELIMINARY. BACK THE
THAT'S FAR. BUT I WOULD HOPE
THAT THIS HEARING IS BUT THE
FIRST THE- CONVERSATIONS THE
WHAT. AARON PARTNERS THE
SHARED. BETWEEN THE STATE. AND
SO I THINK YOU'VE OPPORTUNITY
TO TESTIFY TODAY AND I'LL DO MY
BEST TO ADDRESS IT. IF YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MS MARTIN
YOU INDICATE THAT YOU HAD BEEN
IN IN YOUR TO IN YOUR JUST YOU
THAT YOU'RE NOT INCLUDED IN THE
COMMERCE AND- FOR THE NEW IS
THAT. YES YES AND A MISTER
CLICK HARVEY IS THAT THE SAME
FOR THE LEAGUE OF CITIES WE
HAVE NOT BEEN INCLUDED NUMBER
INCLUDE- THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR THAT I THINK THAT'S PART OF
THAT THE CHILD IS TO WHICH IS
THE- THE IMPETUS FOR THIS
INFORMATION HERE THAT WE CAN
HAVE DIE TIONAL I LOG. MAY HER
YOU MENTION THAT. COURSE YOU
WOULD LIKE TO SEE LOCALITIES
RECEIVE MORE RESOURCES TO HELP
ON ENFORCEMENT BUT BUT ABSENT
THAT IT WOULD THEN BE THE STATE
TO TAKE THAT ROLE. IN YOUR TO.
YES I MEAN AND LESSEN UNTIL-
THAT CITIES CAN RECEIVE SOME
MORE ASSISTANCE OR AT LEAST
MORE TOOLS TO HANDLE ON FORCING
THEMSELVES. YES THEY WOULD DO
FONG THE STATE I WOULD IMAGINE
WE HOPE THAT THE STATE WOULD DO
SOMETHING SURE. AND SO THERE IS
INADEQUATE RESOURCES FOR LOCALS
TO. REALLY TACKLES THE ISSUE
ENFORCEMENT. IS THAT RIGHT YES
AND YET YOU HEARD- ALSO. A FISH
AS WELL AS MEMBERS THIS OF THE
COMMITTEE. AND THIS
INFORMATIONAL HEARING INDICATE
THAT IT WAS. LOCALS THAT ARE
BEST EQUIPPED. TO FOCUS ON THE
ISSUE OF ENFORCEMENT. THERE IF
I MAY- I THINK IT'S REALLY A
PARTNERSHIP BETWEEN CITIES
COUNTIES AND THE STATE- AND
AGAIN. GO BACK TO MY INITIAL
POINT IN ORDER TO DO THAT IT'S
NOT JUST FUNDING THAT WERE
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT SHARING
INFORMATION WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
BETTER COORDINATION BETWEEN
ALL. ENTITIES BECAUSE IT'S
REALLY TAKE A. YOU HAVE TO DO
IT SINCE IN SYSTEM AND IF AN
OPERATOR ONE LINE AND HAVE
ENOUGH. YOU KNOW IT COULD BE
POTENTIALLY- YOU KNOW IT'S AN
UP ALL THE REGULATORY PROGRAM-
SO WE'RE NOT WE'RE TRYING TO
PRIORITIZE ENFORCEMENT TO GO
AFTER BAD ACTORS AND THEN ALSO
SORT OUT WHICH TAKES
COMMUNICATION COORDINATION.
FOLKS THAT AB ARE OUT OF
COMPOUND AND CAN COME BACKTO
COMPLIANCE BUT REALLY WHAT YOU
NEED IS A GREATER PARTNERSHIP
TO BE ABLE TO DO THAT. AND DATA
IS THE FOUNDATION OF THAT RIGHT
SURE ANYTHING THAT'S IS THAT
SIMILAR BY WE APPRECIATE YOUR
TESTIMONY HERE TODAY TO
ILLUSTRATE THE PRINCE OF THE-
SHIP. THAT WE NEED. PERSPECTIVE
UNTIL LOCAL CONTROL YOU HAVE
SEEN. PROPOSALS HERE IN THE
LEGISLATURE LAST YEAR ON THAT
OF LICENSING- WHISKEY LOCALITY
IN HELPING ON THE- REGULAR
MARKET PLACE AND THE PIPELINE.
HOW FOR SEE THE ROLE OF LOCALS
THE TO SAY THAT YOU YOU CAN SEE
THE COMPREHENSIVE APPROACH AT
THE STATE IS TRYING TO TACKLE.
THE REGULAR MARKET PLACE THAT
OF ENFORCEMENT. BUT ALSO IS
THAT THE PIPELINE AND ACCESS
ISSUES WE'RE WILL BE THING
LOCALS PLAY IN TERMS OF APP
HELPING TO ASSIST IN.
RECOGNIZING THE ROLE THAT
LOCALITY PLAY WITHIN THE WIDER
SCHEME OF THE STATE. AGAIN I
WELL SO THE FOUNDATION
OBVIOUSLY- OF LOCAL CONTROLS
AND PROP SIXTY FOUR AND IT
ALLOWS COMMUNITIES TO DECIDE
WHICH THEY ARE AND FRANKLY
IT'S- YOU KNOW IMPACTING
COUNCILS AND BOARD
REPRESENTATION BECAUSE OF THIS
ISSUE IS SO PROMINENT.
COMMUNITY IS REALLY ALTERNATELY
UP TO SECTION TO DECIDE HOW.
AND WHEN THEY WANT TO REGULATE
BUT IN ORDER WE'RE TAKING I
THINK A MORE PROACTIVE AND
INCENTIVE APPROACH FOR FOLKS
THERE ARE NUMBER OF THOSE ON
THE SIDELINES THAT ARE LOOKING
TO THEIR NEIGHBORS TO SEE SORT
OF. THE TRIALS AND TRIBULATIONS
THAT THEY'RE GOING THROUGH AND
WAITING UNTIL THE SYSTEM IS
SORTED OUT BECAUSE IT EVOLUTION.
BUT WE CAN TRIED TO HELP
JURISDICTIONS THAT ARE
INTERESTED IN REGULAR AND
PROVIDING GREATER ACCESS
GETTING THAT 65270% NUMBER UP.
HIGHER UP IN POPULATIONS. BUT
THAT NEED A PROVIDES. WITH
ABOUT AND SO LOCAL WHICH AND UP
HER. DATE EASE OF. EASE OF
INFORMATION AND BEFORE I THINK
YOU YOU CAN LEAVE THE GOAL.
POST PORT BUT TAKING THE
APPROACH DOING THAT. MR GIPSON.
THANK BUT CERTAINLY ENJOY.
CONVERSATION THUS FAR QUESTION
FOR THE PANEL THE- WORSE TODAY
HOW DO YOU FEEL WILL. OF
OPINION ABOUT THE SKIN SO. THIS
IS HOW YOU DISEASE THANK DO YOU
THINK THAT THIS EVEN FURTHER
BURDENS THE INDUSTRY SO I'M
JUST CURIOUS ABOUT YOUR
THOUGHTS IN TERMS OF THIS
PROPOSED CONSOLIDATION CHERYL
JUMP IN AND THEN- TRUST CAN
FILL IN FROM THE SAME
PERSPECTIVE. I THINK IT'S AN
OPPORTUNITY I THINK- HAVING THE
PLETHORA OF AGENCIES THAT TOUCH
ON CANNABIS REGULATION- LIVE
AND EXIST IN VARIOUS DIFFERENT
DEPARTMENTS AND AGENCIES-
DOESN'T HELP FOR BETTER
COORDINATION SO CONSOLIDATING
THEM INTO A SINGLE ENTITY
PROVIDES THE OPPORTUNITY FOR A
FISH AND SEA AND AGAIN THAT
GREATER PARTNERSHIP WITH THE
LOCAL LEVEL. BUT THAT'S ALSO
INCLUDING FOLKS FROM FISH AND
WILDLIFE AND THE WATER BOARD
AND OTHER AREAS- THAT REALLY I
THINK CAN POTENTIALLY DELAY THE
PROCESS INTO THAT CONVERSATION
HAVING POTENTIALLY LIAISONS
WITH THAT TO. THAT'S WHY WE
WANNA BE INCLUDED IN THIS.
BECAUSE FROM THE INVITE. A
REVIEW PERSPECTIVE WE HAVE A
LOT OF EXPERTISE AND FRANKLY
WERE A LOT OF THE DELAY AT THE
LOCAL LEVEL SO WE NEED TO BE-
AT THE TABLE WORKING THROUGH
HOW BEST. TO ORGANIZE EVERYBODY
FOR A GREATER OUTCOME. YEAH I
WOULD AGREE- WITH PRETTY MUCH
EVERYTHING THAT THEY CARE SAID-
I THINK WHEN YOU BRING A LOT OF
THESE- WHEN YOU BRING THESE
ENTITIES TOGETHER AND
SYNTHESIZE ROLES AND
RESPONSIBILITIES ALL IT ONLY
MAKES FOR- EASIER
COMMUNICATION- TO AT LEAST FROM
FROM CITIES TO. YOU KNOW FIGURE
OUT WHO THEY NEED TO TALK TO.
WHAT THEY NEED IN TERMS OF- IN
THE WAY OF INFORMATION TO GET
FROM A TO B. TO ACCOMPLISH
THEIR TASK I MEAN. IT'S SO THEY
CAN ONLY MAKE THINGS EASIER AND
LET FOR I THINK WHAT MAKES IT
EASIER IF WE HAVE THIS. THE
CONSOLIDATION THAT'S BEING
POLLS ACT. AM TO. HELP US TO.
YES THOSE WHO ARE THE UNDER
MARKET AND WE LOOK AT HOW DO WE
NOT TAX THIS INDUSTRY OUT OF
BUSINESS. TO ALLOW THE LEGAL
MARKET TO INCREASE IN OUR
COMMUNITIES THE POLITICAL RADAR
COMMUNITIES AND SO WE REALLY
HAVE A REAL ROBUST CONVERSATION
ABOUT. HOW DO WE- NOT STRANGLE
THIS INDUSTRY THIS EMERGING
BECAUSE I THINK THAT WE HAVE
NOT. EVEN SCRATCHES. IN TERMS
OF BE A MAN SITTING WHAT THIS
IN YEARS YOU CAN ACHIEVE IT WAS
A LEGAL MARKET. FIRST HERE IN
CALIFORNIA AND THE LEGAL MARKET
OF THE MARK RUNNING RAMPANT IN
OUR COMMUNITIES AND SO THAT'S
WHAT I'M HOPING THAT- A
CONSOLIDATION AS WELL AS
COORDINATION DOES FOR US MOVING
FORWARD. BUT WE THE LEGISLATURE
HAS BEEN PART OF THAT THE
LEGISLATURE CANNOT BE ABSENT
THAT AND SO THAT'S WHAT I'M
LOOKING FOR. THANK YOU. SO MY
QUESTION IS HOW CAN WE HELP YOU
HER NUMBER THERE'S NO LICENCES
VERSUS THE NUMBER OF PERMIT
LICENSES. IN THERE'S A- CLOGGED
LOCAL LEVEL THROUGH SEQUEL OR
OTHER ISSUES. HOW CAN WE HELP.
THOSE LOCAL GOVERNMENTS THE
DEAL WITH THAT BACKLOG. WHAT
FROM THE SECRET THAT'S KIND OF
MORE OF A COUNTY- ISSUE I DO
THINK THAT AB NINETY SEVEN THE
TRAILER BILL AUSTER THAT
PROVIDED THE TWO YEAR
EXTENSION- FOR THE SECRETS
SECTION FOR LOCAL PROGRAMS IS
VERY HELPFUL. I THINK AND THE
CREATION OF THE PROVISIONAL
LICENSE WAS MATT REALLY TO GIVE
ADDITIONAL TIME TO LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS- TO COMPLETE THAT
LAND USE PROCESS- YOU KNOW PART
OF THE ISSUE IS THERE'S A LOT
OF OTHER IT'S JUST A
CONDITIONAL USE PERMIT WERE
PLANNING DEPARTMENT THAT HOUSE.
VIEW THESE PERMIT ON THIS WATER
BOARD AHMED THERE'S FISH AND
WILDLIFE INVOLVEMENT SO
INCLUDING THOSE FOLKS IN ANY
KIND OF CONSOLIDATED OR PERHAPS
IN BEING UP SOME OF THEIR
PROGRAMS OF THAT ADDITIONAL
STAFF THEY CAN TACKLE THE
NUMBER OF LICENSES- THAT
THEY'RE GOING THROUGH IT WOULD
BE HELPFUL IN THE STATE SIDE WE
HAVE TO DO THE SAME. LIKE WHAT
IS AT THE LOCAL LEVEL WE'RE
DOING THAT THROUGH- SHE AND TAX
REVENUE BUT IN JURISDICTIONS
LIKE HUMBLE MENDOCINO MONTEREY
SANTA BARBARA THAT HAVE
THOUSANDS OF CULTIVATION THIS
IS. SOMETIMES RELATIVELY SMALL.
IN APARTMENTS. IN ADDITION TIME
THE STATE. I LEGISLATION PASSED
LAST YEAR TO FOR PROVISIONAL I
IS VERY HELPFUL TO US. THANK
YOU FOR THE COMMITTEE. WILL
HAVE NO UP THE PUBLIC COME. IF
YOU WISH TO SPEAK OF THIS.
CHAIR COOPER CHAIRMAN LOW IN
MEMBERS AMY JENKINS ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA CANNABIS
INDUSTRY ASSOCIATION I'M ALSO
HERE ON BEHALF OF BLOOM FARMS
AND CAN CRAFT FOR ALSO BOARD
MEMBERS OF CCA- WE STRONGLY
SUPPORT THE REFORMS OUTLINED IN
THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL- WE ARE
A STRONG PROPONENT OF
CONSOLIDATION. SPECIFIC AND I
THINK IN LARGE PART THAT IS DUE
TO THE FACT THAT THERE'S BEEN A
LOT OF COME ABOUT ENFORCEMENT
TODAY WE HAVE LONG SUPPORTED A
CENTRALIZED ENFORCEMENT SYSTEM
A LOT OF THE EARNS WERE RAISED
BY BY- THE CHAIR AND COMMITTEE
MEMBERS TALKED ABOUT THE
DISTINCTION BETWEEN. LICENSED
AND LICENSE LICENSED
ENFORCEMENT WE BELIEVE THAT THE
LICENSEES HAVE- SUBJECT TO VERY
ROBUST ENFORCEMENT TO ENSURE
COMPLIANCE BUT THERE IS A VERY
VERY THRIVING LIST GET
CONTINUOUS I THINK THE FACT.
THE BY CATION ENFORCEMENT IS
REALLY PART OF THAT PROBLEM SO
WE ARE HOPEFUL THAT AS PART OF
CONSENT SHRIMP TESTED REAL
FOCUSED IN CENTRAL FORCE. XIN
PROPOSAL THE OTHER THING I
THINK THAT'S REALLY IN. IS A
THE BY. OF LICENSES WE THINKTHAT THROUGH CONSOLIDATION- WE
WILL ACTUALLY BE ABLE TO REDUCE
COSTS AND ADMINISTRATIVE
BARRIERS TO ENTRY IT'S VERY
VERY COSTLY TO GO THROUGH THAT
BOTH THE STATE AND LOCAL
PROCESS. APPLY FOR MULTIPLE
LICENSES SO WE LIKE TO SEE- A
LITTLE BIT MORE EMPHASIS ON
SHOULD USE MORE BY FOR. LESS BY
CATION- FOCUSING ON. SAYS CAN
PROCESS CAN YOU MANY FACTURE ON
THE C. PROMISES WERE HOPING AND
CELEBRATION WILL IT PRESS A LOT.
THIS ME I'M JUST GONNA MAKE A
NOTE. TAX EXEMPT CASE PROCESS
WE ARE A STRONG. OF TAX
SIMPLIFICATION. THE AND WE
THINK THAT WILL USE YOURS TO
ENTRY. CURVE. I THINK A PART OF
OUR ILLICIT MARKET PROBLEM IS
THAT WE NEED TO BRING IMMEDIATE
RELIEF TO CALIFORNIA STRUGGLING
CANNABIS INDUSTRY THIS INCLUDES
THE COMPLETE SUSPENSION OF THE
CULTIVATION TAX. AND OTHER
CONSIDERATIONS- THAT WILL
RELIEF AND REDUCE THOSE TAXES
THE IMPOSITION IN PARTICULAR
FOR WEIGHT BASS CULTIVATION TAX
REMAINS ONE OF THE MOST
SIGNIFICANT CHALLENGES FOR
CANNABIS IN THE SAYS. AND A
MAJOR MAJOR BARRIER TO ENTRY A
COUPLE POINTS I JUST TO MAKE AS
A RELATES TO SOME OF THE
COMMENTS MADE ON THE LOCAL
GOVERNMENT CHANNEL. I'M WITH.
BILL PRODUCTS. ACCESS TO FORTY
HIGHER THAN ONLINE PRODUCTS I
I'VE FAILED TO SEE. HE'S S. TO
LEGAL PRODUCTS THEY SUBJECT
TRACK AND TRACE WE A DONE OF
WHERE THAT PRO HAS BEEN USE ARE
NOT PURCHASE THESE PA THEY ARE
PRODUCING THEIR PART A MARK
CHEAP PRICE AND THEN WITH
RESPECT TO SEE SEE A AND SOME
OF THE OTHER TOOLS THOSE ARE
REALLY TARGETED AT LICENSED
OPERATORS AND LAST ABOUT
COLLECTING DATA IN MY AND SO
WHILE WE DON'T HAVE AN STAND
POSITION ON CCA AND
SPECIFICALLY IT IS COSTLY AND
IT'S A WEEKLY REPORTING DATA
SYSTEM- AND DO YOU THINK THERE
SHOULD BE MORE EMPHASIS ON
COLLECTING DATA AND- BECAUSE-
DO. AT ON LICENSE ACTIVITY AND
I'LL ALSO TO WITH WERE TO. MORE
RESOURCE TO LOOK WE SIR STRONG
SUPPORT THAT AND WOULD WELCOME
THE OPPORTUNITY TO PARTNER WITH
THEM IF THAT MEANS A DRESSING
UNLICENSED ACTIVITY THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. THANK YOU. THIS
CHAIR IS A MEMBERS AROUND
MARTIN ON BEHALF OF KHALIFA-
FIRST OFF ON THE REORGANIZATION
ISSUE- WE COMPLETE YOUR SUPPORT
THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL IN
DOING THAT WE DO LOOK FORWARD
TO HAVING- A ROLE TO PLAY WITH
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE AND
WITH THE EXISTING REGULATORY
BODIES IN TERMS OF PROVIDING
INPUT TO THEM AS THEY'RE
PUTTING THIS MODEL TOGETHER AND
WORKING WITH YOUR STAFF AS WELL
AS MOVE FORWARD. ON THE ISSUE
OF THE ILLICIT MARKET- LET ME
TELL YOU FROM THE PERSPECTIVE
OF PEOPLE WHO ARE ON THE GROUND
RIGIDLY COMPLYING WITH
REGULATIONS IS VERY
DISCONCERTING AT TIMES
DISCOURAGING I'M TO HAVE TO GO
UP AGAINST A LIST OF MARKET
COMPETITION- IT IN A VERY
ROBUST WAY- WE WOULD WE WOULD
BE MORE SUCCESSFUL AS AN
INDUSTRY WE WERE LESS GOD.
BLESS IMPACT BY IT BY THE
MARKET THERE ARE THREE BUCKETS-
THAT WE BELIEVE THAT YOU NEED
TO FACE TO FACE IN ORDER TO FIX
US AND I'M NOT TELL ANYTHING
YOU DON'T KNOW NUMBER ONE THERE
NOT ENOUGH TAX SYSTEM THERE ARE
CAN DESERT ALL YOU USE AT THE
CENTRAL AND HOW FOR UPPER THERE
ARE FOR PEOPLE ACCESS LEGAL CAN.
I MEAN THAT PART OF THE STATE
WE NEED TO DO MORE NEED TO FIND
THE MATCH SOLUTION TO GETTING
MORE LOCAL GOVERNMENTS TO STEP
UP THE END WHEN THE PROP SIXTY
WORLD NUMBER TWO IS THAT WE
NEED TO TAX REFORM TAX
SIMPLIFICATION. OKAY SYMBOL.
PORT BUT IF WE DO SOMETHING IN
TERMS OF REAL WE'RE NOT GONNA
WORK ON GOING TO MAKE IT. WHEN
AB TALKS ABOUT THE- BETWEEN THE-
OF LEGAL. AND ILLEGAL. IT IS A-
BECAUSE OF THE TACK CONSERVE.
I'M NOT A HUGE. PROBLEM FOR US
I'M IN THIRD AND THANK YOU
MISTER COOPER MISTER LOWE AND
MISTER LACKEY ESPECIALLY FOR
HIS VENTING- THE ENFORCEMENT
PROBLEM IS HUGE- AND THE
PROBLEM IS OR NOT. NOT UTTING
ENOUGH RESOURCES ON IT I THINK
YOUR POINTS MISTER COOPER
ESPECIALLY ABOUT HOW MANY
PEOPLE IT TAKES TO ISSUE FORTY
FOUR. WARRANTS IS IMPORTANT FOR
PEOPLE TO HEAR- AND IMPORTANT
FOR US TO DO SOMETHING ABOUT
BECAUSE WE DON'T PUT THOSE
RESOURCES. ON THE GROUND WITH
SO OFFICE. DEAL I'M WE'RE NEVER
GOING TO AHEAD OF THE- MARK.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU I'M GOOD
AFTERNOON I'M ON A CHAIRMAN IN.
COMMITTEE HI MY NAME IS CHRIS
OF IT ALL IN THE EXACT DIRECTOR
WITH HERE NOW. CAN FARMERS AS-
OUR MISSION IS TO AND TO CAN OF
FARMERS THROUGH. ADVOCACY AND
RESEARCH SO THEM. OF THE
MEMBERS OF OUR ORGANIZATION OUR
OUTDOOR MAKES LATE HERE ONE
CULTIVATORS WHO TEND TO BE ON
THE SMALL SIDE. I'M I'M- IS
HEAVY IN MANY SEEN NO HOME WHAT
COMPANIES AND ESPECIALLY NEVADA
COUNTY. JUST TO GIVE YOU SOME
KIND OF. VIEW OF WHO IT IS THAT
WE WORK WITH ON A REGULAR
BASIS- WHILE WE GREATLY GREATLY
APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
SEE THE TAX SIMPLIFICATION. I'M
MOVING THE CULTIVATION TAX TO
THE- POINT OF COLLECTION OR THE
FIRST DISTRIBUTION POINT. WOULD
FURTHER ECONOMICALLY CHALLENGED
CULTIVATORS SO THAT WOULD BE
WELL BEFORE THE AWAY THE KURD
AND BEFORE THE PRODUCT IS FOR
SURE GOING TO BE. PATHWAY TO
HAVE THOSE TECH READ TO THE- SO
WHAT WE WOULD RECOMMEND THAT
CASE IS A REAL JUST THIS.
ELIMINATION OF THE CULTIVATION
TAX WOULD GO LEAPS AND BOUNDS
BEYOND THAT SORT OF THIS
IMPLICATION EFFORT- REGARDING
CONSOLIDATION- STREAMLINING IS
THE WORD I LIKE TO USE BECAUSE
STREAMLINING THE LICENSING
PROCESS IS DEFINITELY
NECESSARY- WE SUPPORT IN
CONCEPT CONSOLIDATION BUT- ONLY
IF THAT CONSOLIDATION OF. DOES
NOT CREATE MORE BIFURCATION
BETWEEN CANNABIS AND HEMP WHICH
WE STILL HAVE COMING ONLINE
HERE IN CALIFORNIA. AND
ADDITIONALLY THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF FOOD AND
AGRICULTURE HAS A BROAD RANGE
OF PROGRAMS THAT COULD BE
BENEFICIAL TO CULTIVATORS. ON
DOWN THE ROAD SUCH AS A
COMMISSION SOME MARKETING
ORDERS AGRICULTURAL COUNCILS
BUT ALSO GRANT PROGRAMS THAT
HELP TO SUPPORTTHE
SUSTAINABILITY OF THE GREEN OF.
XIN ARE FARMING OPTICIANS. I'M
AND I YOU KNOW A LOT OF. POINTS
ABOUT. HIS INTERNALLY LICENSE
SO RIGHT NOW WE'VE GOT
CULTIVATOR THAT ARE FOR TO GET
CALL MY BECAUSE THEY CAN PULL A
LIGHT TAR IN OUTDOOR TEAR THEN
THEY CALL TO OUTDOOR IN A LIGHT
UP TIER I KNOW THAT'S KIND OF
HIGH LEVEL BY I IN FORCE
MULTIPLE. UPON LICENSEES THAT
DON'T HAVE A LOT OF RETURN ON
THEIR INVESTMENT OR ABILITY TO
ECONOMICALLY NAVIGATE THE
LICENSE SYSTEM SO I'M THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. IF YOU. THANKS TEARS
COMMITTEE MEMBERS IT'S GOOD TO
SEE YOU GO AGAIN IT'S BEEN A
WHILE I'M MY NAME'S HAS A CHI
ALLEN LAST TIME I APPROACHED
YOU ARE I SPOKE TO USE
REPRESENTING AN ASSOCIATION NOW
I'M A LICENSEE- PENDING
APPROVAL FROM CD HEY HOLD A
LICENSE FROM BCC SEATING PH AND
ALSO WORK WITH AN AGRICULTURAL
CO OP OF FORTY TWO LICENSED
GROWERS- IT'S FOR US TO TAKE A
POSITION ON THE BUDGET PROPOSAL
CURRENTLY BECAUSE WE HAVEN'T
SEEN A PROPOSAL. THE INTENTION
OF CONSOLIDATION IS GREAT
STREAMLINING SOUNDS FANTASTIC
BUT BUT LET'S BE REAL WE HAVE
NO IDEA WHAT WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT AND SPECIFICITY HERE
THERE'S A LOT MORE TO BEING A
FARMER THAN JUST OBTAINING A
LICENSE CALIFORNIA APART OF
FOOD AND AGRICULTURE HAS A
MANDATE TO PROTECT AND PRINT OF
THE AGRICULTURAL PRODUCTIVITY
IN THE STATE AND DO A HECK OF A
GOOD JOB YOU CAN LOOK IT HI OF
BODIES THAT WE LEAD THE WAY IN
CANNABIS ISN'T ONE OF THOSE
COME. IN THERE'S NO BETTER
AGENCIES WE LIVE. THE
CALIFORNIA. PUT IN AGRA. BRANCH
MANAGER PARROT DESPITE SOME
JUST. IN THE PAST IS THAT I
HAVE OF A JOB LEADING THE
BRANCH AND I THAT THE- SHOULD
SHOULD BE. FRONT CENTER IN THIS
PROCESS GOING FOR. TO THE
CONCEPT OF AN- AND THE IDEA OF
THE CARROT AND THE STICK I CAN
TELL YOU WITH CERTAINTY THAT
GIVING THE LICENSING AGENCIES A
BROADER ENFORCEMENT MANDATE
WILL NOT ENCOURAGE MORE
PARTICIPATION. THERE'S ALREADY
A TREMENDOUS FEAR MONTHS THE ON
LICENSE BUSINESS COMMUNITY THAT
SEEKING TO GET A LICENSE WILL
BE THE TRIGGER FOR ENFORCEMENT.
IN FACT WE HAVE WORKED WITH
GROWERS WHO OBTAINED A WATER
BOARD PERMIT AND HEARD FROM THE
SHERIFF THE NEXT WEEK WE HAVE
SEEN. THE ATTEMPT TO GET ON THE
RIGHT SIDE OF REGULATION LEAD
TO ENFORCEMENT ACTIVITY
COUPLING THOSE TWO ACTIVITIES
WILL DISCOURAGE BROADER
PARTICIPATION. WOULD PERHAPS BE
WISE TO EXPLORE MORE EFFECTIVE
ENFORCEMENT. ACTIONS THAT THE
STATE COULD TAKE BUT TO ME.
MUDDY THE WATERS OF LICENSURE
WITH THAT MANDATE SEEMS
INCREDIBLY PROBLEMATIC IN SHORT
I AND ARE STILL IN A PHASE
WHERE COURAGE AND- PARTS. FROM
THE BASE UNITY IS TO BE. WE
NEED THAT RELIEF TO CENTER IT
WOULD BE FOLLY. EXPECT AND
FORCED COULD SAW THIS. FOR
FORTY YEARS OF A EXT. ENFORCED
APPROACH TO. ON ITS AND FORTY
NINETEEN EIGHTEEN AS ONE CAN.
MOVED TO THE VICIOUS LEADING
THE WAY TO COOLEY WE- THINK IF.
QUITE A TIME HAVEN'T TRIED. IS
LOW BARRIERS ENTRY. FOR TO
PARTICIPATE. WHEN IT IS THE
TIME. I THINK ANY I DON'T.
SPEAK MORE I'LL BE CLEAR. ARE
HOPEFUL YOU CAN SENSE IT THE
UNIT IN THE TAX BURDEN IS HOW.
BY THE TIME UP. TO MARKET ON
SOME SOME CHAINS IN OUR STATE
THE- BIRD ON THAT PRODUCT IS IT
AS MUCH AS SEVENTY TO EIGHTY
PER. OF THE- VALUE THAT'S
CERTAINLY AN EXTREME CASE BUT
THAT ANALYSIS DOES EXIST IF WE
WERE TO TAKE A- AT IT. SING
MATTERS A LOT CONSUMER
CERTAINLY CONVENE STYLE TôI
DOES AND WE HAVE A- BETTER. TO
DO TO AND THAT LEAD IS.
REGULATION IS FELT AND IN ALL.
AROUND THIS. BUT UNTIL WE CAN
GET THIS TO PROBLEM UNDER CAN
IT'S GOING TO BE A REAL UP
HILLS SWIM US. ALL SAY THEY ALL
A THE CHALLENGES FOR. MY
BUSINESS RIGHT NOW- AGAIN
HOLDING LICENSES FROM TWO OF
THE AGENCIES UNDER REVIEW FROM
THE THIRD AGENCY. AGENCY
CONSOLIDATION WOULD NOT BE HIGH
ON MY LIST. IT'S NOT A PRIORITY
THERE'S A LOT OF OTHER THINGS
WE NEED TO DO IT'S A HALF
COOKED PROPOSAL AT BEST. THE
INDUSTRY HAS BEEN CONSULTED
BROAD THIS IS THE LEGISLATURE
IN THE LOW GOVERNMENT HAVE. GOT
A LOT MORE WORK TO DO ON THIS
TO MAKE SURE THAT WE GET. SURE
THAT WE DON'T THE BAY OUT THE
BATHROOM. THE MULTI AGE.
FRAMEWORK WHICH- RIGHT. EFFORT
IS BUILT IS VERY IMPORTANT AND
THERE ARE SOME REAL UPSIDES TO
IT THANKS FOR THE TIME GUYS
APPLAUD YOUR EFFORTS. IF YOU
HAVE COMMENTS PLEASE IN LINE.
GOOD AFTERNOON AS CHAIR MEMBERS
BUT REALLY YOU WANT TO HAVE A
U. D. W. ASKED ME LOCAL DURING
NINE THIRTY WE REPRESENT
HUNDRED SEVENTEEN THOUSAND HOME
CARE PROVIDERS AND TOLD MY
COUNTIES THROUGHOUT ALIFORNIA
AND MANY OF OUR PROVIDERS AND
CLIENTS HE'S CAMPUS AS MEDICINE
FOR RELIEF- IN TERMS THE
PROPOSAL'S TODAY WE ARE
SUPPORTIVE OF THE IDEA OF
CONSOLIDATION OF THE THREE
LICENSING AUTHORITIES TO HELP
STREAMLINE LICENSURE REGULATION.
AND WE BELIEVE IN. OF THE LOCAL
PANEL THAT PRESENTED TODAY
THAT. THE UPTAKE IN THE LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS ARE LICENSING
ESTABLISHING THESE FRAMEWORKS
IT'S A MOVE IN THE RIGHT
DIRECTION. AND WE SHARE THE
SAME GOAL OF MOVING MORE
OPERATORS INTO THE REGULATED
SPACE AND WE LOOK FORWARD TO
CONTINUE DISCUSSIONS. TO ENSURE
HEALTH AND SAFETY OF
CALIFORNIA'S INCLUDING THE MOST
VULNERABLE LIKE OUR CLIENTS.
AND LEGAL ACCESS THANK YOU VERY
MUCH THANK YOU VERY MUCH. WANT
TO TAKE A FOR COMING TODAY IN
THE COMING SHE MAYES THIS YEAR.
YOU KNOW WHAT. FOR HEATING WE
WANT TO HELP BE INVOLVED IS NOT
EVER SEE JUST FOR. TO SIT HERE.
IT WOULD COME SO. AND THERE'S
MUCH FURTHER TO GO. IN DEALING
WITH AND THE LEGISLATURE HAS TO
BE SKY. I MEAN IT'S BEING DONE
IN A VACUUM. AND IT DOESN'T
MAKE FOR A GOOD FINAL PRODUCT
IT'S WORTH IT FROM DAY ONE I
THINK MAKES A LOT EASIER AND
OUR FIRST OUR FEAR IS THAT- WE
DON'T GET- ANY DIRECTION ANY
PLANS. INTO ME THE VICE. OR
LATE APRIL. YOU KNOW THAT'S NOT
THE WAY THAT DO LIST. SO
STAFFED WITH THE ON OUR SIDE
FOR READY AND WILLING TO HELP
AND AN DIVORCE UP IN. AND
REALLY HELL MAKE A BIG IN THE.
MR LOOK. THIS ARE HEARING.